speaking before the senate victoria
nuland confirmed there are bio labs in
ukraine and that the us is concerned
russia may seize them and that the u.s
is working with ukraine to figure out
what to do with these biolabs now of
course we've been getting an endless
stream of media claiming it's all a big
conspiracy theory and these fact
checkers do something interesting
they fact check an extreme version of
the story so you see this meme going
around saying that russia was striking
u.s bio labs and say oh it's all fake
it's all fake
that way when someone says oh but
ukraine does have bio labs people assume
it's the same story and they're actually
quite different so we will take our time
debunking the actual fake news and
showing you this testimony about actual
biolabs in ukraine i think is
significant because if we're trying to
understand how to end this conflict with
peace and negotiations diplomacy we kind
of need to know what the complaints are
from the people who invaded granted i
think putin is in the wrong completely
he invaded but it makes sense to
understand the full context of the story
so we're going to that joe biden his
banned oil and energy all energy imports
from russia gas has set a new record
high and everyone's basically saying
it's going to get a whole lot worse and
stephen colbert says what's a couple
bucks for a clean conscience a couple
bucks per gallon that is so for all of
you have to commute to work and don't
make that much money maybe you're making
15 bucks an hour congratulations it's
going to cost twice as much to fill out
the gas tank but it's okay you'll have a
good a clean conscience so we're going
to talk about all that stuff we also got
the parental rights and education bill
in florida passing democrats call that
the don't say gay bill which is a
complete and total lie in fabrication
because the bill has barely anything to
do with that subject matter it's funny
the bill mostly is like if a kid has any
kind of medical issue the parents have
to be told that that's and that's
basically it it's like things that
happen in school parents need to need to
be told about it and so now all of a
sudden democrats are marching around
saying gay over and over again it's kind
of weird but we'll get into that joining
us to discuss these issues today is greg
price how's it going man i'm good it's
good to be back on i'm uh greg price
i work i'm with a company called x
strategies llc we are advisors and
digital strategists for a bunch of
conservative politicians and non-profits
and super pacs and we work to elect
america first candidates and unelect the
rhinos um the ceo of our company today
had to testify before the sham january 6
committee shout out to alex brujawicz
for having to suffer through that today
too yeah and um enrique taro got
arrested
yeah conspiracy
on january 6 even though he wasn't there
they're claiming that he was involved in
planning or something
well yeah that's the thing they're
they're hauling people before this
committee who had nothing to do with the
right at the capitol they're trying to
simply criminalize everyone that
supported president trump well they're
saying on average this a response to the
subpoena for january uh the january 6
committee costs a hundred thousand
dollars yeah they're wasting your tax
dollars no no your money you need to
hire a lawyer and spend a hundred
thousand
personal money to answer the subpoena
yeah that's yeah that's true alex had to
do that and it's been really terrible
for him and that's what they're doing
they're just going after all of these
people that had nothing to do with it
but simply supported donald trump i also
forgot to mention mcdonald's is shutting
down over 800 locations in russia too so
golden arches theories golden arches
because they know two countries that
have have a mcdonald's won't go to war
with each other not true but
yeah no that's why they're doing it it's
a fact
sheamus cognitive freedom tunes by the
way happy happy to be here uploaded a
new cartoon today about our military
preparing for world war iii and the
lgbtq diversity policies i think you
guys might enjoy it if you want to go
check that out thank you very much yeah
i was just looking at average california
gas prices now we're five dollars a
gallon family times with an image of a
six dollar and thirty cent gas so like
you could have said it was over six
dollars it's just the way that they're
free from things it's seven bucks in l.a
i saw seven dollars and sixty cents but
their consciences are really clean yeah
yeah for now yeah i think people don't
realize that um
you know vehicles in california are
around good intentions yeah so all those
clean consciousnesses yeah love will get
you to your destination
your conscience is going to be i'm sure
colbert's conscience is going to be
really clean when food becomes all but
entirely unaffordable for poor people
because gas prices have gone up and it's
more difficult to get food grocery
stores people don't realize this is why
they virtue signal so much so they can
power their vehicles
yeah that's right emotions
when you're paying 70 for a tank of gas
and your grocery bill goes up by a
thousand dollars a month all you need to
do is think to yourself at least we're
helping ukraine yes
that's what it's all about man yeah
that's right we got lady pressing the
button i'm also here in the corner i'm
excited for tonight's conversation
because i spent most of the day very
upset about the price of gas i saw that
went up eight cents a gallon overnight
in colorado and it hit a new record here
as well so hopefully i'll be able to
keep calm and we'll be able to make some
good progress tonight
but before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support all of our fierce and
independent journalists who are
reporting the news every single day and
as a member you get access to exclusive
tim cast irl shows we put those up
monday through thursday at 11 p.m so we
will have one for you tonight and my
friends tomorrow is my birthday so you
can get us a birthday present by signing
up and i will remind you again tomorrow
if you want to help support the show and
that's a great birthday present no you
don't have to but we really do
appreciate it if you help keep this
machine operating so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and let's jump into the first story it
is but a tweet
from glenn greenwald who says ukraine
has biological research facilities says
under secretary of state victoria nuland
when asked by senator rubio if ukraine
has biological or chemical weapons and
says she's worried russia may get them
but set but she says she's 100 sure that
if there's a biological attack it's
russia
and actually
marco rubio
intervened in her in her uh her answer
to answer for her and it is one of the
most disgusting things marco rubio man
talk about a bad person but let me play
for you this clip because this is truly
revealing well um i only have a minute
left let me ask you
um
does ukraine have chemical or biological
weapons
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may seeking to
gain control of so we are working with
the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach i'm
sure you're aware that the russian
propaganda
groups are already putting out there all
kinds of information about how they've
uncovered a plot by the ukrainians to
release biological weapons in the
country and with nato's coordination if
there's a biological or chemical weapon
incident or uh or attack inside of
ukraine is there any doubt in your mind
that 100 percent would be the russians
that would be behind it there is no
doubt in my mind senator and it is
classic
russian uh technique to blame on the
other guy what they're planning to do
themselves
wow if there was anything that could
remove all confidence i had in what
victoria newland was saying it's marco
rubio teeing up the answer to her of
course if there isn't it's russia right
you agree it's russia yes okay then yo
just let her answer the questions but
but i digress here we have under
secretary of state saying
well there's uh
there's bio labs in ukraine and we're
concerned rush could get them now let's
just put aside anything outside of this
because there were conspiracies i i
don't know anything outside of that let
me just say
is it is it a serious concern for us in
the united states that ukraine has bio
labs what are they researching i don't
know what if russia gets a hold of them
is there something there that we should
be concerned about is this may be why
vladimir putin says i'm going into
ukraine because that was what a lot of
people were saying now that's not a
conspiracy theory if you are speculating
that the motive of vladimir putin was to
gain access to research facilities i'd
say that's war like if you have a
military base and another country
invades to gain control of that base i'd
be like okay
so is that maybe what we're looking at
well i just want to mention something
about secretary of state newland here
she's very interesting figure so one
thing that she mentioned
in 2013 is that the united states
government had spent over five billion
dollars trying to promote democracy in
ukraine and there was a leaked phone
call between her and america's
ambassador
to europe where she was discussing who
who she thought would be a good leader
for ukraine and wouldn't you know it
just happens by coincidence a couple
weeks later that person becomes prime
minister
and yeah and so we talk about how
russia's spending 46 and not even russia
non-state actors in russia spending 46
thousand dollars on facebook ads was a
quote-unquote act of war
and the united states government has
thrown literal billions of dollars at
ukraine to influence their leadership
this woman was on the phone on record
saying there was a specific person she
wanted in charge of government there
that person ends up in that position
weeks later
and i'm supposed to trust this person
that they have the best interest of that
nation in mind and that she's going to
tell me about russia's nefarious deeds
the cia just overthrew i mean they were
part of the coup
of uh ukraine when they put in
poroshenko and yeah i mean that's that's
just on the table now
2014. everything i look at says there's
overwhelming evidence the united states
now that we've accepted that the cia has
been involved with the overthrow and i'm
like is there evidence that says that
what we need that that's not this is
what so it's not
this every time i ask it they're like
yeah it's totally totally confirmed
i thought you were on the show like last
week no no it was heavily speculated
first of all there were major protests
in ukraine it is widely speculated
believed the west was well first of all
it's a fact the west was very much
supporting the euromaidan protests that
doesn't mean the u.s
made yanukovych flee there's a big
difference between the cia actually
having agents and assets going in and
doing these things
now that being said i would not be
surprised in any sense uh that the the
that this i did this did this i'm just i
want to be very very careful and precise
yeah because
what i'm saying then because we're
dealing with the fact that the under
secretary just said there are bio labs
okay let's start from there is russia
pissed about that very well maybe
now we have this story from music today
this is why getting the fact perfect is
important
they say fact check false claim of u.s
bio labs in ukraine tied to russian
disinformation campaign
so right there you have interesting
points u.s bio labs okay well they're
ukrainian according to vic
victoria newland she said ukraine has
biolabs so you see how they do this they
slap us bio labs in front of bio labs
and all of a sudden the whole story's
fake yeah so yeah exactly they fact
check a different story than the one
that's actually being discussed and then
anytime the story comes up they get to
slap false on it so here's what they say
the claim there are bio labs in ukraine
funded by the u.s government now i will
i will say we we read on this show a u.s
government site talking about u.s funded
research and bio labs in ukraine so i
don't know what that was all about they
say in the early morning hours putin
launched a full scale military blah blah
blah
similar posts claimed russia destroyed
seven of the 11 supposed labs and
missile strikes the claims are wrong
independent faction outlets reported i
actually don't think those claims are
true to be honest because we looked at
the map of missile strikes in the map of
labs and they don't line up it's like
weird that people would make that claim
when all you need to do is say
putin's mad about labs he's probably
blown up stuff near the lab so that he
can take the labs
yeah i would assume russia wants the bio
labs as newland actually said in front
of marco rubio regarding russia would
seize them if it's war or not i think
historically you see border skirmishes
that aren't considered war like if if an
enemy is setting up artillery on on the
border on the other side of the border
from your country you may send in a
party to destroy the artillery and then
come back and it's not really an act of
war it's more of just like or sometimes
they'd go in and they'd steal food from
like the enemy but it wasn't really war
you ready for this part of the same
article oh yeah the same article says
the ukrainian and u.s governments
partnered in august 2005 to prevent the
proliferation of dangerous pathogens and
related expertise and to minimize
potential biological threats according
to the treaty interfax ukraine reported
in may 2020 that part of the agreement
was aimed at modernizing state
laboratories in the odessa kharkiv
leviev
those efforts included making repairs
updating equipment and purchasing
supplies
the security service of ukraine to the
laboratory's finance from the state
budget are subordinate to the ministry
of health and the state services on food
safety and consumer protection according
to interfax ukraine the u.s embassy in
ukraine sought to set the record
straight on these bio labs claim in
april 2020 calling the theories
disinformation spreading in some circles
in ukraine that mirrors russian
disinformation regarding the strong us
ukrainian partnership to reduce
biological threats it sure sounds like
they're trying really hard to claim that
although the us did partner and help
ukraine with a lot of the work they were
doing in certain biological areas these
are not u.s bio labs okay well no that's
true they're not they're ukrainian but
is the u.s involved i'd sure like to
know well usually they hire a company
like eco health alliance to get involved
for them so that they can wipe their
hands of it well yeah what's with our
country and like funding all of this
insane biological research around the
globe as you know we saw with the the
wuhan lab too and i think you know this
goes back to i you know the way this war
has been presented to us in the media is
that you know ukraine is the good guys
who can do no wrong and everything we
have to take
the government of ukraine's word over
over anything else and as we've seen
we've been fed so many so many lies as
this war has happened between you know
imminent nuclear meltdown that turned
out to be false as zolensky was calling
for a no-fly zone and i think it just
goes back when you're in a war
propaganda is very important and
propaganda to help your side win is very
important and a lot of that is being
a lot of that is just being fed to us by
our media i want to read the last
portion of this article they say because
this is interesting based on our
research we write false the claim that
there are u.s bio labs in ukraine funded
by the u.s government the posts
misrepresent a treaty between the united
states and ukraine aimed at preventing
biological threats the labs are owned
and funded by the ukrainian government
the security service of ukraine and the
us embassy in ukraine have said the
claim is false reports indicate the
claim is tied to a years-long russian
disinformation campaign aimed at
discrediting the us okay fair i totally
accept all of that okay so ukraine does
have bio labs right so when when the
narrative came out that russia was
concerned about bio labs in ukraine
that was legitimate yep like is russia
really concerned about that all right
sorry sorry everybody you know that
they're spreading this disinformation
how about we just talk about the truth
that there are biological research
facilities in ukraine and that russia
wants to seize them well because or the
u.s fears russia will yeah well like i
said on our last episode the only time
you need to really come in with these
fact checks is if there's some kernel of
truth that you don't want people
discussing that seems to be the case
very often maybe i'm being a little
hyperbolic but we see it frequently and
i will say this after the last five or
six years it is absolutely laughable
that they think they would have any
credibility talking about a
biological laboratories bioweapons labs
and where they're getting their funding
and b russian disinformation it doesn't
exactly bolster my confidence in the
veracity of their claims that they're
using that phrase
look at this look uh we have the story
from bloomberg this is funny china
pushes russia conspiracy theory about
u.s labs in ukraine russia wouldn't just
put russia in i don't know why they
labeled it that way titled it that way
foreign ministry urged u.s to name
viruses stored in labs
yet to call russia's military action and
invasion i bet the word russia gets
better clicks better like internet
search results than russian that's why
they did it you a fan of that bio lab
name three of their viruses sorry yeah
and this is this is literally the same
these are the same types of headlines
that we saw at the beginning of the
covid pandemic with the one people were
pushing the lab leak theory i'll never
forget the one from the washington post
when they literally said tom cotton is
repeating a conspiracy theory about kova
that has already been debunked like this
is the same exact game plan that they
did when kovitz started with the la when
they covered for the lab leak from china
what i'm starting to notice is when you
debunk something it doesn't mean that it
wasn't right well the difference today
between disinformation and something
that's true is only a couple weeks or
months now or days yeah yeah or even or
even or even days in this case bio labs
itself was a conspiracy theory yeah but
it's because what they do is
if you bring up to a journalist what's
up with these bio labs in ukraine they
immediately retreat to the mat and go
like oh u.s doesn't have bio labs in
ukraine he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa i didn't say us right said what's
up with these bio labs so what happens
is you'll get a regular person
and like i've experienced this it's
really funny you know people shouldn't
play games with me because i know what
i'm talking about and i'll say something
and they'll you know there's this is a
really good example
so i'll give you a hypothetical but
because i don't want to invade i don't
want to violate anyone's privacies but
so you'll say something like did you
guys hear about you'll be at a party and
you'll be like do you hear about these
bio labs in ukraine now now they're
confirming it russia of course probably
is not happy with it and then someone
goes
there's no u.s bio labs in ukraine
you're making that up and then i'm just
like
i never said us a regular person though
might be like of course they're always
reading about it and then they'll pull
up on their phone and they'll say there
are no u.s bio labs see everybody he was
wrong
that's what they'll do and people will
conflate these stories and not realize
it don't play games with me because i'm
going to be like i didn't say u.s my
favorite part is that that's the stuff
you talk about at parties
no i'm not i am serious yeah yeah of
course i do also i walk into a party i
got a beer like how about that bio lab
everyone's like oh yeah yeah and we're
all drinking i just gotta say i really
hope they're not eating bat soup in
ukraine seriously because that's the
most logical explanation of where
biological weapons come from right you
were a conspiracy theorist if you
thought that the virus which was first
infecting people right near a biological
weapons research lab was made in a
biological weapons research lab instead
of coming from a bat so so what happens
is you've got all these labs in ukraine
and china's saying like tell us what
viruses are in it in like a month all of
a sudden there's like 12 new viruses
that emerge in ukraine and then the
mainstream media goes that was an
armadillo that one was ukraine's bad
infestation problem so i don't know it's
gonna be a different animal for each
different virus
from the biolab but the sad thing is
it's there it's serious like when i was
so when i was at the daily caller back
when covid first started we were one of
the first news outlets that ran stories
about the potential for that that this
virus came from a lab and we got dinged
on facebook for it the way facebook
works is the way you get one of those
fact checks on your post is a fact
checker has to write an actual story one
of their certified fact checkers has to
write a story about your post and you
get dinged and if you get a certain
amount of them you get your account to
monetize we got one for running lab
league stories like this is the media
and big tech and you know the deep state
working together to suppress information
that they don't want the public to know
but they apologize of course right oh
well yeah eventually they you know
eventually when it all came out oh i'm
kidding they actually did that's well no
no they didn't apologize no of course
they didn't apologize but when the info
finally came out that actually there is
merit to the lab league story they
stopped the censorship remember when um
that was what was that guy's name andy
stone is the guy from facebook he's on
twitter and he's like the hunter biden
laptop story is you know disinformation
over so we're suppressing it to make
sure it can't be shared and then twitter
did and then like a month later they're
like oh that story was real
like they publicly brag about
suppressing pertinent information to an
election that happens and that guy too
used to work for the d triple c and
barbara boxer and a bunch of other
democrats too so you had this democrat
comms guy who now works at facebook
talking about how they're censoring a
story that's unfavorable to the then
democrat candidate for president you
know what concerns me right here is that
there's gonna be a leak this is the
narrative okay the two biggest fears in
the world right now kovid and russia
they're gonna that there's gonna be a
leak in ukraine and they're gonna blame
it on russia and it's gonna be another
pandemic well so so that's exactly what
we heard with marco rubio just in the
other segment rubio's saying there's no
doubt in your mind you know ms newlin
that if there's a biotech it is russia
yes the priming now if something happens
they're like we told you it was russia
time for us to invade marco you know
marco rubio oh you know you said it was
gonna be russia how conspiratorial do
you want to get very seven remember
remember when uh remember when
bill gates recently was talking about uh
weaponized smallpox yeah what was that
story again what an odd thing to talk
about yeah you wanna pull it up real
quick see if you can pull it up there
was a story where it was like bill gates
was talking about treatment for like
weaponized smallpox he's like we
speculate it would evolve from a bat
yeah it was gonna be an animal but like
this time it's a penguin
like i think these penguins are gonna
give us weaponized smallpox it was a
hamster the penguins will fight back
yeah
bill gates warns of weaponized smallpox
just after fda approves his new pox drug
this is from november 29th 21
2000. that was actually recently so this
is the independent yeah so we have it
right here bill gates warns of smallpox
terror attacks as he seeks research
funds yeah now look this just could
could be you know him being like i'd
like money please
or maybe we should pay attention to what
powerful global elites are saying about
stuff when you have people like rubio
saying there could be a bio attack so it
could be a smallpox thing i don't know i
don't know if these things are connected
i don't like speculation i just want to
get on the record saying it now so that
in in six months if it does happen uh
people know that i was thinking it i'll
i'll put i'll put it this way
you can you can take it the the
pessimistic nefarious route and assume
bill gates knows something or we can
trust bill gates he warned us about
weaponized smallpox now we're hearing
russia might do a bio attack
dude
funding eco health alliance which was
working and he was thinking of a more
trustworthy did you not is that not on
the i don't know i thought he was for
sure i know that the nih was and was
bill gates doing it oh i don't know i
don't know that's the guy you got
government yeah man i could be very
precise
shut
you you guys are really i'm not saying
you're wrong you could get a fact you
could get fact checked for it yeah no
but like let's let's make sure we're
accurate
was bill gates in any way providing
funding to ego house bill and melinda
gates foundation they did i'm looking at
it now see if you find anything so i'll
i'm gonna put it this way i'm gonna give
bill gates the benefit of the doubt even
though i don't like the guy and say okay
maybe he's right and knows something
about the potential terror attacks yeah
bill melinda gates foundation committed
a 1.5 million dollar grant to the
eco-health alliance in 2020. see there
you're you're alrighty yeah you know i
was just saying just make sure you fact
check it because we got to be very
precise i knew that so i just i wanted
to we were
we knew that you were testing ian that
info comes from influencewatch.org but
is that is that a legitimate i don't
uh
bill gates celebrates collaboration with
nih from gatesfoundation.org also is
that right let me see they're pretty
well there you go i mean honestly it's
not it's not far-fetched to believe that
bill gates is providing um
uh is providing this you know financial
assistance to this organization i mean
he he talks about vaccines oh yeah it's
on the gates foundation website they
support india's ministry of animal
husbandry whatever so let's just go
ahead and say maybe bill gates when he
warns of smallpox terror attacks kind of
knows something we don't
i'm not saying he's malicious conspiracy
i'm saying maybe he's right maybe he's
right and we should be worried i'll just
tell you this whatever you want to
believe that there's a grand cabal
planning these things and bill gates is
involved or bill gates is a superhero
who's saving people
there seems like a risk of smallpox
terror attacks so um i don't know what
you do do you just you know buy
emergency food and hiding i buy
emergency food yes hydrogen i'm dropped
with tunes obviously
i'm going to buy uh some
shipping containers and bury them and
crawl into it and die you know what i've
heard shipping containers not the way to
go though because they cave in
yeah they're also they're not made
they're not really made to sustain uh
weight geodesic domes right yeah but
they also they leak that's the biggest
problem with them i've been doing a lot
of research on those too okay how about
how about we get giant floating domes
well so you know what the real massive
vacuum them out you create like um when
you gotta live in it you create a
chamber it's like a boat you you vacuum
out the boat area of it so it floats the
real flex is not that you go to an
underground layer when it hits the fan
it's that you force your enemies into an
underground layer can we make something
strong enough to withstand a large
enough vacuum to actually float on yeah
i think it's going to be a meta material
like um arrow gel yeah like a graphene
arrow gel and then what you do is you
create a bunch of little pockets of
holes inside of this boat and then you
vacuum out all these little pockets of
holes so you've got like a light lighter
than air
thing and then if it's big enough it
should be able to carry people and farms
and stuff so that it's yes it would be
as a whole it would be uh
it would it it's it's not the mass it's
the um displacement of gases and then uh
you strap an ion thruster on it and fly
it around
what do you think is something
i don't know
i don't know but lydia i just d back to
our topic or talking about bio labs i
check out the tweet that i just dmv it's
back to reality
it's a it's a guy writing for foreign
policy and
foreign policy.com like you know the
preeminent foreign policy magazine and
he says russia helped create his and is
now actively amplifying a conspiracy
theory claiming the invasion of ukraine
is being done to destroy u.s run
bioweapons facilities and he says the
wildest part people believe it yeah so
this is from march 2nd so yeah
but this is the thing it's like you know
foreign policy that's you know that's
held up as like this you know by the
establishment as this you know what's uh
this trustworthy news outlet that's the
title yeah this is it false claims of
u.s bio warfare labs and ukraine grip q1
right well look i got no problem saying
i don't see why we have to talk about
u.s bio labs or whatever like if that's
if you want to fact-check that like by
all means i'm not if ukraine has bio
labs
sounds like it's a fact because victoria
lin said they did now the question is is
this emoting motivating factor for
russia i don't know because russia their
demands of of ukraine are give them don
best give them crimea and don't join
nato or the eu right i didn't see any
demands from russia where they were like
get rid of these bio labs
so
i think the story could be a stretch to
say the least but i just love how they
they this is a trick look if you've been
watching the show for some time you know
the trick because i tell you all the
time you'll have ian
and i'll do a backflip and the media
will write did ian really do a backflip
on sunday yeah
false
yeah while ian did do a backflip it was
actually at midnight on saturday which
is technically not sunday although
technically it is we rate this claim
false yeah it was 11 59 in 58 seconds by
the atomic clock standard unfortunately
for ian it's clockwork it was actually
monday in australia when he did the
backflip on sunday
partly true
it's not a u.s lab they're ukrainian
labs and they're not bio warfare labs
they're just bio labs so if you put bio
warfare it's going to be called false
too according to the girl that you see
these games they're playing with this
stuff sneaky yeah
man i love this one
politifact just goes nuts with it
bloggers say putin bombs biden owned
villa in ukraine while hammering biolabs
and pedo rings
all right well i'm gonna give you that
one politifact that sounds like
that is a little if this is the problem
it's because there will be like a guy
wearing like a nice suit and he'll be
like you know what i'm concerned about
these bio labs in ukraine and then there
will be like a crazy guy that tinfoil
hat next to him going like you're right
the u.s is funding them and they're
speedos and then the fact checker goes
i'm gonna run with that one or or those
two people actually hate each other in
real life but the media associates them
with one another as is the case with the
infamous conspiracy theory pyramid that
i reviewed and debunked on my channel
the
point is you want to link people who
have basically nothing in common other
than the fact that they're questioning
the official narrative there's a comic
that's being shared by all of these
leftists and it's the weirdest thing and
it shows a guy sitting on a couch with
what appears to be his wife or something
and he's got a shirt with an american
flag and he's wearing a red hat and i'm
like gee i wonder what that supposed
symbolize and he's watching the news and
he says
russia says they're just taking back
what's rightfully theirs
and then the woman goes alaska was
russia's you know 60 years ago or
something and i'm like
is this implying that the america first
anti-interventionist populist maga
people
are
like defending
you like russia's invasion of ukraine i
don't understand like i don't
it's it makes no sense you you can try
to do an honest analysis of putin's
motives and reject a lot of the
propaganda coming from the warfare state
in the industrial military complex and
their lackeys in the media without
supporting putin or his invasion right
well tim to your point what they're
doing is exactly what you say they can't
find anyone in real life who actually
supports putin they can't find
republicans to support putin so they
have to create this little comic there
this is the whole of twitter is
imagining someone and then getting mad
at that person right like that person
literally doesn't exist but you're gonna
sling those narrows at him because it's
easier the best the best they can do is
find republicans who putin supports at
least according to them right exactly
they're trying they're really trying and
it's kind of sad because
there are actually real things that we
could be working toward fixing together
but no it has to be russia and even
though we don't have any problems that
need fixing right now yeah yeah we're
good let's let's let's crank this up to
11. daily mail says u.s official warns
cornered russian leader could use small
nukes on ukrainian cities in worst case
scenario after kremlin officials
privately denounced putin's cluster f
invasion with his forces bogged down in
snow and minus 20c freeze on the way
i kind of want to just say at this point
bullish like all of it they're coming
out and they're like
yeah russia could do a bio attack there
could be nukes and i'm like okay look
look look hold on
when they talked about the invasion i
said starting to sound like chicken
little and then there was an invasion so
far be it for me i have no i have no
moral standing at this point to claim
putin won't be using nukes because i was
certainly wrong by him invading kiev but
at this point i'm just like yo you've
beaten us over the head screaming about
the escalation and putin is crazy over
and over again can we just chill for a
minute yeah well i mean look the moral
of the story of the boy who cried wolf
is not that those stupid village people
didn't believe him the one time he was
telling the truth
is that he kept lying and so he lost all
of his credibility that's the exact case
with the media maybe they maybe this is
the one time where they have real
information about something that's
actually gonna happen
well they did phrase it as it may it's
their fault it's their fault that people
don't believe them because all they do
is lie sheamus
we can get this project done in a half
an hour let's do it you should draw up
we'll work together we'll make a book
called the democrats who cried russia
and it'll be a children's book not
really it'll be like but like
where like the first few pages explained
russiagate and i was all fake yeah and
then and then in the end when the
democrats finally came out and screamed
rush is going to invade no one believed
them and then putin invaded and attacked
that's 100
russia
after seven years we just didn't care
anymore or like they're like yeah the
media that cried anything
yeah the media that cried racism or
fascism or whatever i don't know you
guys so look i don't necessarily think
it's wrong i want to add one one thing
to this story too this idea that
vladimir putin is dying so this is
something that's been reported over the
past several days they're claiming he's
got terminal bowel cancer
and i'm just kind of like
you know look he does look a little
sickly but he could be getting old but
to claim that there's like there's
there's scant evidence it's an anonymous
source claiming he's got terminal bowel
cancer we've had great luck with those
anonymous sources over the past couple
years i don't i don't know if i i don't
i definitely don't believe that either
because did you see the video of putin
that went viral a couple months ago of
him playing hockey oh really no yeah um
it's really funny because he's like he's
playing in a hockey game and all of the
other players on the ice are just like
letting him score of course
but i mean he was playing goals i mean
he was playing if he could do that i
don't really think that he would be
terminally ill yeah but he also just
take time off
did he know yeah a little while ago he
took like a few weeks to a couple months
off i don't know but you remember do you
remember like i forget when this was
this was probably over a year ago when
there were reports going around that kim
jong-un was on his deathbed that was cnn
too cnn was like reporting like it was
cnn reporting that kim jong-un was on
his deathbed basically just caused an
international incident and that turned
out to be false you know what's funny
we got these reports about you know a
cornered putin will use nukes a dying
putin is dangerous mad vlad and it's
like
the media is going to end the world do
you guys if the world ends it'll be
because there is a hysteria driven by
media who wanted that one last click
yeah i've got another example do you
guys remember the time that the media
lied to us about every single thing they
ever told us for the entire time they
existed
that was called my life yeah good times
i feel like it's it's also not just that
they lie it's that they completely
ignore real problems that matter a lot
more to americans so they've been
obsessed with this invasion in ukraine
we have an invasion at our southern
border right now but the media portrays
that as compassionate that that that
america just that the bind
administration just allows this to
happen also we have an invasion in libya
and in iraq that we're perpetrating
right now that you don't see much
much of this talking about it
unfortunately you should do a bit where
cnn hires jessie smallette
and then everyone's just like we trust
him i mean it's similar most believable
guy redemption it's his redemption
and he can he can talk he can always he
can be holding a subway sandwich as he's
always reporting the news reporting live
for mega country because you know i'll
keep saying it every single time like
right now i can just be like the media
that beli the people who believe jesse
smallett are lecturing me about bio labs
in ukraine yeah not gonna happen this
time ladies and gentlemen so the thing
about these news articles this says
western intelligence suggests they're
not saying that it's real they're just
pointing out that the intelligence
suggests it and then the other one is
like he may use or he could use people
people could throw lasers out of his
arms and shoot them too people familiar
with the matter have said that putin
might use nukes
my favorite thing is people familiar
with a person's thinking yeah like how
does that mean well i'm familiar with
the media's thinking and i think they're
completely full of it i'm familiar with
ian's thinking and i'm reporting that he
plans on buying rocks
uh he may be right
i i'm reporting ian maybe rolling a 20
at some point let me let me give a shout
out to our possibly i just i just i just
remembered a great example of one of
those stories uh this i gotta give a
shout out to my friend ben williamson
who uh used to work for mark meadows and
there was a story like a little while
ago um when the media was like someone
familiar with mark meadows is thinking
and ben is like it was his senior
advisor and he just goes with all due
respect to the person familiar with his
thinking this story is [ __ ]
i want to give a shout out to our good
friends daily wire who very very
carefully crafted this headline in two
ways
mad vlad western intelligence suggests
putin terminally ill terminally ill
reports so what they're basically saying
is first of all we're not saying he's
terminally ill and those who are
claiming it are only kind of claiming it
so the daily wires really hedged this
article quite a bit yeah basically it
seems like everybody's kind of like i
don't think he's sick you know i got to
be honest though i mean you know maybe
regardless of whether or not he's
actually got bowel cancer or anything
like that dude is 69 average life
expectancy is what 72 in russia i
imagine that's a stressful freaking job
too yeah and i exactly i'd imagine in
russia it's probably lower right maybe
yeah someone google that yeah yeah i'll
pull it up i think i think there's a
good possibility it's not necessarily
about him being terminally ill but him
being like
i'm old and before i pass i'm gonna see
russia you know return to its former
glory it could also be him understanding
that he is never going to have the
opportunity of a leader as completely
inept as joe biden being in office ever
again he probably knows that joe is not
going to last the full term so he wants
to get it taken care of now looks like
russian life expectancy 66 years old for
a man 77 for a woman
so he's he's passed his his you know his
average world health organization going
off what sheamus just said what was that
article you were showing me right before
the show where like the saudi about
house they did people like this didn't
take i'm trying to remember what it was
um hold on one sec i think that um
biden was trying to make a call to putin
and he wouldn't take a call from putin
but he did take a call from the uae or
um
the uae took calls from putin or
whatever
yeah there we go yep yeah it's wild wait
so putin denied putin denied uh biden's
call yes come on man you've got a soul
man it's wild but it's is uh this guy's
there's a zero percent chance that ever
happened no there's no
i was saying this in the day the thing i
love about that story is biden thinks it
makes him look good to say like i i went
to that foreign leader and i called him
mean
you have no soul man and i think that's
what i said russia's like is that it man
it's always good it's like you kind of
want your adversaries to think you're
mean don't you yeah yeah there's also so
many of those like similar stories with
biden where he claims he did all of
these things i know that he never like
he like he always claims that he like
marched he was arrested while protesting
with nelson mandela right like that
never happened he's like oh man i was i
was there but it's the mandela effect
yeah you guys you all remember the
difference be there to experience it
right this would be a great short film
is biden's mandela
actually happened all these stories are
real check it out the corn pop story the
mandela story also he also hold on the
the speech he gave in the 80s yeah but
then something happened with a large
hadron collider yeah and then joe
biden's like standing there i'm a victim
of time travel a rift opens up and he's
like whoa come on man and then he gets
sucked through into a reality where he
didn't do any of these things well putin
banged his straight razor on the curb to
get it rusty put it in a rain barrel to
get it rusty and then it wasn't just a
stream
let's pitch to the daily wire a sci-fi
about joe biden traveling through the
multiverse
it's interstellar but just with joe
biden yeah
oh my gosh and like for some reason he's
interested like matthew mcconaughey is
the same role doing the same things but
it's joe biden in every other capacity
for some reason
come on man traveling through uh
traveling through uh other dimensions no
malarkey he comes from a universe where
people like still frequently use the
phrase malarkey and that's why it's cold
he's fighting everything he's doing all
these wars because he's trying to
restore the original timeline and
vladimir putin's trying to stop him so
it was like putin and and biden met at a
young age and worked together and then
had a falling out when when you know the
large hydrogen collider goes off and
sends them into different dimensions and
putin trying to stop him
i mean it could work it could work as a
sci-fi plot in his universe having hairy
legs as a sign of nobility
got a hairy legs
they get hairy in the pool
there's also the one with the the the
amtrak guy have you ever seen this one
he tells this story so he tells the
story all the time he's told it like a
bunch of times he's talking about public
transportation about how
he says about how he was a senator he
would travel to and from dc to delaware
on amtrak and like there was this guy
uh some italian dude i forget his name
who who he said like came up to him in
like 2019 or something when he was vice
president and was like and he always
like fakes the italian accent and he's
like he tells him you don't know mamma
mia and he's like you know how many
miles you traveled on amtrak and he like
i forget the number of miles but it
turns out the guy died like 10 years
before before that
i'm telling you it's wrong universe oh
my god i mean let's i i want to be with
you guys uh biden has like some plates
in his brain doesn't he yeah he does
does he really yeah he's like i didn't
know that he did things he had like two
aneurysms or something he did yeah so i
it's it's like honestly maybe the real
story is much more sad it is his brain
is just
not working it's genuinely sad the oh
it's genuinely sad
but it's also terrible and worthy of
ridicule that he's president of the
united states
and that no one's willing to acknowledge
that he has severe psychological and
cognitive deficits well well
that's just a stutter you know yeah
that's my point dude have you ever like
you ever had like a stutter that forces
you to plagiarize somebody
else's so weird when that happens
remember dude oh my gosh remember that
one time that i said poor kids are just
as bright and talented as white kids
it's like i stutter all the time
i want to tell you about this
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
that we have uh
he has the kind of tourettes where you
blurt out famous historical quotes
you can't blame him for it
but what's even sadder is that kamala
harris is even worse
with saying nothing saying a lot while
saying nothing at all it's amazing isn't
it she's not like she's not like
slurring and misspeaking as often when
she does she just says
[ __ ] that makes no sense yeah she'll say
a whole paragraph and you'll feel like
there's a lot of words but i don't know
whether i don't know what you just said
i don't think i don't know and frankly i
don't think you were telling the truth
yeah i don't know no no there's no truth
to be had when you're like stringing
random words together it's like lips
our children
and when we talk about our children yes
the
schools it's very important freedom
you're like what freedom i have no idea
what that means but she's standing there
and she's talking what's that meme where
was like international women's day have
you seen this one it's a great no and
it's like be brave like amelia at the
bottom oh i saw that it says speak like
come along and people are like are we
really encouraging young girls to speak
like kamala harris just laugh maniacally
it's time for us to do what we have been
doing and that time is every day
oh my gosh that's ukraine beautiful
ukraine is a country yes russia is a
country yes ukraine is a smaller country
russia invaded ukraine so basically
that's wrong
is that what she said yes she said that
she said that on some like radio shows
yes they were like can you break this
down
the guy was hold on let me find the
quote
it is time for us to be doing what we do
every day
time is now let me find the full quote
because it's actually one of the
funniest things ever and like and i so i
tweeted the video of it that day and i
had so many blue checks who got mad at
me for not including the whole thing
even though the whole thing didn't even
like make her look that much better
um but hold on let me find this yo here
it is she was like ukraine is a country
so the host of the show asked her to
break down what's happening in ukraine
in layman's terms and she goes ukraine
is a country in europe it exists next to
another country called russia russia is
a bigger country russia is a powerful
country russia decided to invade a
similar country called ukraine so
basically that's wrong
that's what she
that is a third grader's history report
50 years from now and it's like and it's
like i i i i didn't do the reading
i wasn't
little little jimmy do you want to read
your report my report is on the start of
world war iii ukraine was a big country
but russia was a bigger country and
russia's invasion was wrong that's an a
plus right there if i've ever heard it i
wasn't aware that the average layman in
america is a kindergarten i know right
yeah my gosh why is russia man i go into
a lot of detail about why russians and
russia's invasion was wrong and i'm like
i'm pretty sure the people who listen to
me can understand my argument as to why
it's wrong whether they agree or not
kamala harris
this is the craziest thing i suppose you
need to understand her audience democrat
voters they really do need it dumbed
down i guess
i don't know
but but she's not but that's the thing i
guess that's an example of it being
dumbed down but a lot of the times it's
not dumbing things down it's making them
really incoherent yeah well i mean what
is she saying that was like explaining
to a five-year-old yeah exactly no that
was a five-year-old explaining it yeah
did you guys see the little golden book
of kamala harris
oh gosh why but here's oh yeah for real
like so little golden books are like the
the little elf climbed the tree and then
there's one where it's like kamala
harris is the president because she's a
woman or something like that what
sometimes people like people and
sometimes
the media wants to force you to like
someone no that's exactly right and like
you have this woman who is the first
black and female vice president and
we're supposed to celebrate this and as
as yeah and asian but we're supposed to
celebrate that as like this giant
victory for women that kamala harris is
vice president even though she was
chosen for the job specifically because
of her race and gender right after she
dropped out of the presidential race
before iowa because she was polling at
two percent in her home state and earned
no delegates and earned zero dollars he
got one right yes and like yeah
and basically said that there was
validity to the claims that he was
guilty of sexual assault and he's like
you want to be my my vp man she's like
of course i do you guys uh remember the
feature om episode where lila plays
blirn's ball yes so this one it's uh so
futurama is amazing and leela is
she keeps hitting the players it's like
baseball basically she keeps beating
them and so they're like we'll hire her
as a novelty act
and she's like wow the first female
blernsball player is like yeah but
you're like a freak show she's like wow
like
that's where we're at i guess like just
be you know and then and then they have
um
jackie
jackie robinson i guess
is actually good at the game and says
you're making us all look bad so we had
to get involved kamala harris may be the
first female vp but like isn't like that
kind of a bad thing because she's making
women look bad weren't we told that
she's the first president the first
female president yeah that's true and
jill biden said she was president as
well at this point it's canon yeah
that's canon
for the rest of time women will have to
know that the first female vice
president of this country was a very
incompetent person who was chosen
specifically because of her gender when
i like to laugh sometimes i like to
google back from right after the first
democratic debate in 2019 when kamala
harris's campaign sold t-shirts with her
picture on it when she was a kid that
said that little girl was me
they sold t-shirts of it
for saying that when she said that to
biden i triggered a whole bunch of blue
checks because i tweeted
that it would be kind of it would be
kind of uh upsetting or it would be kind
of lame if the first female president
gained the office through the death of
the president and not through the
election of the people of the country
and they all went nuts on me over this
and it was a really weird thing i'm like
why am i how am i why are you doing i'm
right you know what i mean like if the
first president is appointed and not
elected that's kind of lame like
shouldn't we be like we've done it
people have elected they've chosen to
vote for this woman instead of being
like joe biden won and he picked her and
then if he gets you know incapacitated
she became president no one picked her
no one voted for she was appointed
that would be kind of lame how do you
know people didn't vote for joe biden
because they liked kamala oh well
probably no to be to be honest though
i'm sure a lot of people did a lot of
people probably were the feminists and
the ones you think so because well but
this is the thing joe biden picked her
to pander to progressives because he
promised he was going to pick a woman of
color but basically every progressive i
know really does not like kamala you
know come on really don't like her it's
true but they don't they they claim that
like joe biden they all voted for him
100 percent like like they're kind of
like
i remember watching contra points
explain why you should vote for joe
biden and i remember watching a bunch of
progressives explain why you should vote
for joe biden and their arguments were
always because trump x y or z of course
and i remember my explanation for why i
personally was voting for trump and it
was school choice it was him setting a
timeline for getting out of afghanistan
it was the the best economy of our lives
in 2019 into 2020 like there were real
tangible things he was proposing where i
was like i like those things i don't
care about joe biden he's an
establishment guy but i can give you a
real argument based on the guy i'm
choosing to vote for for the people
voting for biden they're like trump is
bad and i'm like well biden's bad too
but they vote for him anyway well he's a
product of sort of the the rabid
desire of the media of you know
permanent washington to remove trump
from power because he was the biggest
threat to the establishment's power that
we've ever seen in politics and that's
exactly what they did you know i i think
you'd be very hard-pressed to find
somebody who voted for biden because
they were very excited to have joe biden
as president that's 100 not true and
they voted for him because they were
riled up but because they were convinced
that donald trump was just this biggest
threat to democracy that ever existed
and they used they weaponized the
pandemic against him the fact that this
happened during a pandemic year and they
you know they were basically saying that
every coveted death was somebody donald
trump murdered and between like
obviously big tech and the media being
extremely biased to one side between
states uh you know completely
overhauling their voting laws because
just you know justifying it because the
pandemic you had this perfect storm
where you have this guy now who is
essentially a puppet of the
establishment that was threatened by
trump who's now ruining our country
well yes what you get with joe biden man
let's talk about this story out of uh
out of russia let's talk about the
escalation we have the story um
mcdonald's announces temporary closure
over 800 locations in russia the fast
food giant said it will still pay the
salaries of its employees in both russia
and ukraine i think we might we must
have an error on the teamcast.com
website because this says maca o harack
that's not right that's not mcdonald's
oh i'm kidding it's in cyrillic
i love this
it's funny yeah the the
mac donald's it's an it's like a
weird-looking a
do-ha rack that's what it looks like
it's a cursive r i guess this is just
crazy i mean
facebook leaves russia mcdonald's leaves
russia the big banks leave russia like
they're trying to fix this place yeah i
know
so a lot of people are joking that like
russia's gonna end up being the
healthiest place on the planet
well i wasn't on chile it was very
disturbing because uh diet coke had been
it surged into the country basically in
the last the decade prior and obesity
was rampant it was really disturbing i
gotta i got to be completely honest when
i heard that mcdonald's and facebook and
google and apple car and master were all
pulling out i was like i really would
love to be
like to experience
that right now just to like you wake up
and it's quiet it's just quiet you walk
outside and you look around and you
don't hear anything and you're like a
woodpecker in the distance and you're
like and that's it that's the only
information it's just like
so the people in russia i'm sure in all
seriousness are probably i don't think
they're freaking out over mcdonald's to
be honest they're probably worried their
atms aren't working or they're probably
worried i think march 9th tomorrow is
the last day for visa mastercard to work
so they got to switch over apparently
the local banks are going to keep
facilitating visa and mastercards
internally so visa and mastercard can't
shut that down so they're probably going
to be fine yeah that's what i meant when
i was referring to the big banks by the
way is visa and mastercard pulling out
this
deloitte there's like ernst young
there's a bunch of big financials uh
international financial organizations
that are cutting off russia there's a
lot like it's it's not even that too
like fifa banned russia's soccer team
from the world cup yeah the c h video
games yeah
those cats deserve everything they're
getting that's right this the chl which
is the canadian junior hockey league
which is like one of the biggest you
know junior hockey leagues in the world
you know a lot of they banned russians
from being drafted into the chl
um and you know i did my part when i was
at the bar the other night somebody
ordered a moscow mule and i immediately
just punched him in the face
perfect not a true story
right that's gonna be
russia right now is that adidas is
shutting down their stores and we all
know that they only wear those track
suits right
no more no more russian mafia this is
the borg attempting to digest to the
russian issue no i think it's it's
vomiting it up
all of these like international
institutions are leaving russia it's
it's like imagine there's a giant
like squid alien creature with its
tentacles all over all these countries
and something happened to where they're
like rep they're like pulling away from
russia and it's finally clearing a path
the vines are being torn away and now
russia is just like
i mean these these look
if you are one of these people who
thinks late stage capitalism is awful
you should probably be happy these
companies are like
pulling out of russia because i got to
be honest i understand making life
harder for russians and affecting their
economy is a bad thing
but google facebook mcdonald's going
away would not be concerned because if
there really was a revolution in the
united states like a good healthy
revolution that the
corporate govern like the global
corporations would just cut us all off
we would lose mcdonald's from mcdonald's
and our money our bank accounts our gas
would go up to ninety dollars a gallon
or whatever that's true no you're right
there's something there just buy an
electric car yeah it's just buy
electricity yeah just buy something
because you got 60 grand no problem
don't worry about guests right you get
an electric car energy you get an
electric it's also just like a giant
virtue signal too because these same
corporations will never stop doing
business in china because they have so
much more financial interest in china
like all like they're all read that word
what about a taiwan what does that word
say
i can't temporarily yeah temporarily
yeah temporarily yeah yeah what does
that mean until they until they want to
stop basically it means they're not
really doing anything yeah they're uh
temporary it's especially funny with
fifa too because the world cup this year
is literally being held in qatar
not exactly a friendly country to human
rights aren't there like uh human bones
in the structure literally world cup
stage they're using slave labor to build
the stadium and when and i've heard this
could be wrong i could be wrong about
this so definitely factor me about fact
check i heard when the slaves die they
just push them into the construction of
the building and just build over them
well i don't know if that's i don't i
don't know i can't i can't confirm or
deny but i know from my uh history class
that that's what they did to build the
pyramids yeah and the great wall of
china historically i don't know if
that's true though i was reading about
the pyramids or yeah i i think great
great wall china is what i meant to say
great walmart makes sense i mean it's
massive did you worry about that well
for sure seeing forced labor at world
cup stadium from the bbc in qatar this
is from 2022. yeah i heard they just
like put the bodies into the
construction of the building like they
just when that when they're sealing off
an area cementing it they just dump the
body and then pour the cement over it
and feel like me are you serious i've
heard that i thought hyperbolic yeah no
no no legit like wow i've heard some
some of those stories but it could just
be propaganda qatar migrant workers
unpaid for months of work on fifa
stadium this is from amnesty.org
so people are going and they're not
getting paid migrants are coming in and
getting basically forced slave labor
yeah so hats off to fifa for banning
russia from their video game while
they're about to host the world cup
guitar hope you guys make some money
from the world cup
that's why you're doing it right yeah
right so uh guardian says 6 500 migrant
workers have died in qatar since the
world cup awarded is it cutter or qatar
either okay it depends on who you ask
yeah it's like how you can spell
healthcare with either a space or all
one word right well it's funny to me
that mcdonald's is coming out of russia
and they refuse to do anything about
china where they are actually actively
racist in their commercials mcdonald's
themselves is like company they
basically endorse it they just go along
with it because it's what china wants
anything china wants china i guess is a
much bigger deal in russia and yeah and
like going off that like
obviously we're mad by how expensive gas
has gotten due to the fact that the
world is sanctioning of one of the
biggest oil producers in the world
imagine if china invades taiwan and all
of a sudden all these same countries are
now sanctioning
china which produces like 80 of the
ingredients in our medicines and a lot
of our semiconductors like i know we
complain about the price of gas but
imagine we're sanctioning a country that
produces so much of our manufactured
goods on the upside maybe china won't
invade taiwan because they will be
sanctioned like this and they'll have
total cut off from the global economy
so i don't know about that that story
about bodies being in the stadium
because that might have been propaganda
to manipulate but i did see a report
that said 34 deaths in the construction
of the stadium and now i'm looking at
this story about fifa and inundated with
17 million requests for world cup
tickets so it's just kind of like
you know
this is a country that we've heavily
criticized that uh exploits people to an
extreme degree and we're like yeah but
they're cool russia it brings a new
definition to built on the backs of
slaves
literally
alive today than there's ever been right
incredible dude i was just coming to
terms with just accepting the slavery on
earth right now like
this plastic was i mean these materials
these apple materials are built by like
slave labor in china i don't know the
specifics but like
okay
use it like fuel to fix the system but
it's horrifying
it's the way things are man that's
screwed up yeah this is the reality
think about it
we really don't think about this yeah
that often
it's not it's not even necessarily
that's americans
and it's mostly these democrat types
don't want to talk about it they're
they're the ones who get uh who get
angry and make the comics dismissing any
criticism of them
protesting issues that they actually
support right so when you have people
saying at occupy wall street like all
these billionaire elites and then they
put up a shrine to steve jobs i'm like
let's see a little hypocrisy there like
this is the guy who's exploiting labor i
i despise apple products designed in
cupertino i absolutely love apple it's
like they you know i remember i had a
friend who was in college and
she was like my school is making me buy
an apple desktop for for design and i
was like
why
and she's like you have to otherwise
they fail you and then i was like
except
you can get the same powered computer
running the mac os for a third of the
cost if you just build it yourself and
she's like they won't allow that yeah no
it's crazy i absolutely despise this
company man no i and as somebody who
works in the creative field who does
animation who's spent a decent amount of
time around other animators there's
absolutely no reason that you need to
use a mac to create work that's
ridiculous but apple played it really
really smart by making it these these
these college kids would get student
loans and they'd spend a thousand bucks
on a three hundred dollar computer
and then proprietary charger and
everything and it's like what what what
is the mac os like a rebranded unix
system
i don't know probably yeah i think it is
and so then all of a sudden you get
occupy wall street they're like next
good and we're gonna celebrate put up a
shrine for steve jobs trending looks
cool you know what man i will say this
the virus thing ma'am they don't get
viruses
that's a lie right that's a lie they
don't everyone i know every everyone i
know who has a mac has said they don't
get viruses on it and absolutely in the
early days of the excellent marketing
from apple
uh
there was the narrative saying that
apples don't get viruses and it just
works and that's technically true what
was happening was
apples were less likely to get viruses
because their market share was like oh
yes
yeah there aren't as many nobody was
making them now and the same thing is
true for linux people say like oh well
ubuntu doesn't get viruses either and
it's like yeah because like point zero
three percent of people are using about
granted you know a lot of stores like
walmart i don't know i don't know
specifically walmart but a lot of big
box stores use linux for all of their
point-of-sale terminals and
self-checkouts because it's free yeah
they don't want to pay but i think i
think walmart might use xp or something
dude all for all my talk about not
trusting the media i bought their
narrative about apple not getting
viruses shame on me
but one thing i was i was pointing out
earlier was uh i love that they write
designed in cupertino on their products
it's like you mean made in china i don't
care if it's designed here yeah
you made it somewhere else
i didn't think that like nobody thought
that you were having the people working
in the sweatshops design the products
you're not progressive for doing that
here designed in my luxury apartment
ladies and gentlemen we got breaking
news from project veritas
new york times national security
reporter says the january 6 media
coverage over the top and the fbi was
involved
nyt national security correspondent
matthew rosenberg contradicts his own
january 6 reporting quote there were a
ton of fbi informants amongst the people
who attacked the capital quote it was
like me and two other colleagues who
were there outside and we were just
having fun i know i'm supposed to be
traumatized but like all these
colleagues who were in the capital
building are like omg was so scary i'm
like eff off i'm like come on it's not
the kind of place i can call someone i
can tell someone to man up but i kind of
want to be like dude come on you are not
in any danger these effing little dweebs
who keep going on about their trauma
shut the f up they're effing [ __ ]
they were making too big a deal they
were making this an organized thing that
wasn't will i stand by those comments
absolutely except when james o'keefe
confronted i i don't know if it was this
guy who did he confront this guy on the
street or another uh another journalist
he confronted him uh they wouldn't
comment on any of this stuff i don't
think this was this one
he just posted let me where's my phone
do they because usually when they do one
of these they confront the people in the
video did they do that in this video i
haven't seen it yet i think i want i
want to i want to fact check make sure
in real time that i'm right because i
follow the sierra james o'keefe and uh
no okay so right i was right it was
someone else right mark mazzetti
was the guy that got confronted by james
o'keefe over uh i believe this story so
you have this guy this is this is
matthew uh national security advisor
matthew rosenberg who's saying these
things and a different new york times
reporter was being uh was being um
questioned or challenged over it so
the point of this story i'll tell you
first and foremost
the media these journalists they believe
exactly what we've been saying that it
was bad but come on you're traumatized
it wasn't that bad that there were fbi
informants involved behind the scenes
they all know it publicly they won't say
it they won't report it i'm wondering
why anyone should care at this point if
the new york times comes out and says
there's no evidence there's the fbi
involved is anyone going to listen do
you care if other people who are dumb as
a box of rocks listen what do you do you
can't convince them there's dumb as a
box of rocks
well it's funny that he is reporting uh
ostensibly on the side of the media
there's a new york times reporter he's
upholding the narrative and then behind
closed doors he's saying this is pretty
much nonsense i'm over the narrative it
just goes to show that what the
polling has said is valid which is that
more americans want to see the 2020
riots investigated then want to see
january 6th investigated it's something
like less than half of americans it's
it's
40 something percent 46 percent uh think
that the january 6 committee is good and
they want the investigation to continue
and two-thirds of voters want congress
to investigate the 2020 riot so people i
mean the narrative is falling apart even
among the people who are supposed to be
forwarding it correct
there are also two reasons why you
should care about about what about that
and the first reason is you know all the
people all the non-violent defendants
from j6 that are still in jail without
lawyers without trials they're being
hunt they were hunted down by the doj
and the fbi these people for trespassing
charges and locked them away the second
reason you should care is because this
january 6 committee in congress is
targeting republicans that had nothing
to do with january 6 they had nothing to
do with the riot at the capitol they are
simply political opponents of people on
the committee one of those people is my
boss alex brusjowitz who all he did was
organize several peaceful protests
against the election he did not go into
the capital on january 6. he was not
involved but he got a subpoena and had
to testify today another example is uh
andrew serabian and arthur schwartz who
are two more uh gop strategists they got
a subpoena and they weren't even there
or working for trump on january 6
they're simply friends with donald trump
jr and running a super pac that's
opposing liz cheney so why why why
aren't they refusing well they are well
they are well you know because you can
be held in contempt like you can you can
have criminals well yeah you can have
criminal charges filed against you but
there there's the the charges i think
bannon got like a misdemeanor you know i
don't know yeah i don't i don't know
what's gonna happen but i'm wondering
why so many people are just like okay
alex jones pleaded the fifth well yeah
on the legal well it's different on the
legal side like when we just talk about
it you know it seems like it'd be easy
to do that but these people are putting
the full force of government on on a lot
of these innocent people that didn't do
anything wrong i think republicans are
pathetic
i was going to swear
but i try not to
but um overwhelmingly pathetic
yeah well whenever you have republican
leadership complaining about how the far
left has taken this country too far in
that direction you have to ask why did
you let them right well there's just so
many people who are like you know a good
example is the don't say gay bill
we'll get into in a minute i don't i
don't want to derail into that i just
want to highlight how even conservative
outlets are referring it to it by that
instead of calling it the actual title
of the bill or just like h.r 1557 or
whatever
they're and they're going along with it
i'm just like that that's why i like the
other day we mentioned christina peshaw
the spokesperson for desantis when she
called the anti-grooming bill and
basically called the democrats groomers
i'm like no that's what i call spine or
when ronda sanders walked up to those
kids and was like you don't gotta wear
those if you don't want to
you know take please take them off and
he i think he said later that he didn't
want people to think he made them do it
she's like i don't care if you wear it
just you know i'm not making you do it
so
too often
we have uh people who are just like i'll
just you know i'll do what i'm told and
i'll go along with their abuse of power
you get donald trump what what what did
the republicans do when uh the first two
years of donald trump's presidency a
whole hot nothing yeah
or or what i'm sorry i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry for the president i'm so sorry
that my party acts this way they had
they had they had congress
and they gave it up it didn't do
anything yeah yep
they're not going to do anything
now they're going to just keep
collecting a paycheck sorry go on no
it's just they need term limits this is
ridiculous as a point of clarification
eric with project veritas is telling me
that they did confront rosen oh they did
things yeah that's coming out uh in the
future all right yeah i'm just saying
the video they posted was of mark
mazzetti right right
because every time they do one of these
they always confront the person about
what they said and usually they just run
away from them so here's a journalist
saying it wasn't organized like outright
saying it wasn't organized
that's interesting reporter you know
we've got to trust nyt okay yeah yeah
yeah behind closed doors they tell you
one thing dude our institutions are
controlled by evil despicable people and
there's no real political opposition the
republican party for the most part is
the no way don't party just do it in a
couple weeks from now no wait don't
we're losing we're being beaten down
every policy we push forward is a half
measure and the democrats are getting
what they won
better not push too hard you don't
understand they're like they're like
here's the art of the deal you start
with the compromise
and then they'll give you what you
really want no no no shame as they're
saying here's the art of the deal you
start with the compromise and then you
give in to their demands exactly you
just give them everything they want
i mean the gun issue is that and then
they like you then they're then they're
your friend and they won't call you
racist anymore how many republicans have
come out and been like abolish gun law
restrictions none yeah i mean
it's not really fair i think margaret
taylor green and lauren very small
handful but those are radicals tim yeah
well it's hilarious i've said this on
the show before but whenever a
republican actually tries to reverse
left-wing policy rather than simply
upholding the status quo or arguing that
our rights should be intruded upon more
slowly they're referred to as a radical
even though the whole point of their
position is for them to reverse that
which the left is put in place
i'm waiting i'm waiting you guys keep
talking i'm waiting for source
confirmation on some some breaking facts
i'm thinking about the history of
leadership governments and stuff most of
them i think have been pretty bad over
the years like if you take a thousand
years you probably got like 960 years of
trash leadership and then you get these
great these people that are so good
because they're just actually good and
then they call them the great or
something like that they give them these
titles because they were actually
intelligent people somehow they got into
power that didn't get themselves killed
uh it's not common throughout history
it's very rare to see a fantastic leader
and a good governance you know hammurabi
did it that was like not eight thousand
years ago or something stupid yeah i i
just wanna i just wanna say i i kind of
don't understand how this show exists
because we push back on each other no no
i mean like you've got the new york
times outright lying about all this
stuff you've got the government coming
and rounding people up into solidarity
confinement and somehow we're able to
criticize them very heavily and keep
talking about this and showing like
veritas and and pushing back on it
i'm just like
after everything we've seen after every
media organization has lied about almost
every single story how does it show like
this i think it's because don't hold
your breath buddy yeah
much more time
i mean i think i think the success of
this show kind of derives from that when
people where people are waking up to the
fact that all these people do is lie and
all they are are tools for the large
corporations and the establishment in
this country and shows like this aren't
and that's what
what i mean is why hasn't youtube taken
because the people in charge are are not
they're they're being coerced by the
military industrial complex no one wants
freedom of speech gone like the people
that are really in charge of google
don't they're not evil they're just
being coerced by the staff by this
established force i would like if they
were truly evil they would have shut it
down a long time ago well i mean that
that may be true but i i kind of i think
you're rolling around here i want on
this one i don't think you need to
censor people i think you just need to
assassinate their character obviously at
some point they do want to censor we've
seen them do it before people have been
deleted from youtube but why take down
tim's show when all you have to do is
say tim pool is a far right extreme he
doesn't want anyone who repeats what he
says is a bigot but that doesn't work at
some point it doesn't you're correct and
i think that's when they do start taking
people down but
the average person is still too afraid
to talk about these things at their
place of work or somewhere when they
aren't sure that they're surrounded by
like-minded individuals unfortunately i
am kind of curious how long hopefully
you have on youtube and i'm glad we put
our stuff on other sites and i'm glad
that we have the website i would like to
mention as well i've got some uh just an
update from veritas themselves
that their next installment is
discussing new york times sources the
nsa and the cia and that they do
confront this individual so this should
be interesting but um
i think people at google are evil i
think people at twitter are evil i think
there's a combination of evil and the
banality of evil and i do know it comes
up a lot but it is a good reference
point the the joe rogan twitter episode
that i did where i think you need only
look at
when i was talking with jack and said
what is your reasoning for the
misgendering policy and they said oh
because you know certain people have a
higher propensity towards suicide and i
said what about people with body
dysmorphia or what it's called it's
called general body
dysmorphia something like that people
who want to like cut off their own hands
or something oh yeah and they didn't
have an answer to that yeah or when i
said if conservatives think your
misgendering policy is inverted why do
you side with only one half of the
country instead of yeah so clearly
they have a world view completely
detached from yours they're willing to
silence and do whatever they want
because in their world view it's what we
were talking about yesterday they're the
within
the two apparent factions of the culture
war there are those who believe in
inalienable rights whether you're
religious or not there are people who
believe there exists something outside
of you and people other people have
equal right to life liberty and
happiness happiness and then you have
the woke cultists who believe that power
is derived by force and they can take
whatever they want
so that's like
you know overarching narratives here we
here are like honest because well you
should decide for yourself in your life
because i respect you and your your life
and you do what you want the other side
believes that power should be seized and
you seize power by lying and lying to
people and manipulating them well as
jack dorsey said to him if conservatives
are allowed to express their views on
twitter trans people aren't safe to
express theirs so censorship is actually
promoting free speech did he actually
say that that's not exactly how he put
it but that's what he i mean that's what
he said his whole argument was that
transgender people are not in a safe
space where they can speak freely unless
those who would quote unquote misgender
them are unable to do so let's talk
about that's not a misrepresentation of
this argument that's what i mean that's
what he was saying and
i'm sorry no no just to make another
point about that i think you know it
goes back to the fact that republicans
controlled the presidency and both
chambers of commerce or commerce
congress for two years
and didn't do anything about big tech
censorship there's there are
there are laws that can be changed that
can prevent these big tech companies
from censoring people and republicans
just didn't do it
the good news is i think a lot of the
gops start a lot of gop politicians and
a lot of are starting to wake up and get
it and understand that hey
we can make reforms to section 230 we
can make reforms to these laws that can
that can you know stop big tech from
censoring people and we'll see if it
happens huh i wanna i wanna bring up
this clip from uh tom elliott on twitter
oh yeah stephen colbert he says i know
what his name actually is he says today
the average price of gas in america had
an all-time record high of over four
dollars a gallon okay that stings but a
clean conscience is worth a buck or two
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon heck i'm willing to pay
fifteen dollars a gallon because i drive
a tesla
i don't i don't want a pro abortion
capital don't talk to me about a clean
conscience maybe what's
what does he mean by clean conscience
what is that no clue what is that
reference to i don't know
climate change or ukraine one of the two
yeah well why would it be climate change
electric vehicles buying less gas he
didn't he didn't say anything about yeah
he said buying gas
so it's russia yeah except the price of
gas isn't going up right now because of
russia
we only just today banned imports of
russian energy so this is colbert
manipulating you manipulating regular
people but i'd like to point out as i
stated a moment ago why should i care if
a bunch of npcs sing in the audience go
ha ha ha ha ha ha at a guy who's lying
well there's a thing that comes up that
says laugh it's like blinks so they know
when they're cued to laugh and clap it's
it's all theater and then literally in a
theater and then them laughing and
clapping cues the audience to know that
they're supposed to laugh and clap yep
and you know it also goes to show just
how out of touch you know the elite in
this country is with regular people you
know stephen colbert's worth millions
and millions of dollars if the price of
gas goes up it's not going to affect him
as much as it is somebody who has to
spend like 20 30
on their gas tank to get to work every
day how about a progressive cost of gas
so the richer you are the more you have
to pay when you go to the pond and i saw
i saw this one
i'm kind of joking because i don't want
them to track people's income but how
about that there's a meme uh it's from
cat turd and he said there should be two
different uh gas pumps those who voted
for for trump pay two dollars and those
voters voted for didn't pay take it
colbert just said he wouldn't mind
paying 15 a gallon and he can afford it
well no because he drives a tesla
because he can afford a tesla i mean how
do you say something like that and not
think does this make me sound
ridiculously out of touch
today the average average gas price in
america had an all-time record of four
dollars a gallon
let them eat cake
exactly let the let them use electric
cars that's right he basically said
that's literally what he said why don't
you just drive a sixty thousand dollar
tesla why don't you just get your chest
judge said the same thing twice once in
november and then once again monday
it's like maybe it's because people
can't afford a forty thousand dollar car
maybe like the economy is the worst
that's ever been like i don't know when
someone takes an injury that's not the
moment to start like shaming them about
getting healthy when they're hurting you
that's not when there was also there was
also a time like years ago when he was
on comedy central where stephen colbert
was actually funny yeah like late night
long time ago
and late night comedy has just become
trash and the reason it's become trash
is because one it's not even comedy
anymore and it's too
comedy is supposed to challenge people
and make fun of the people in power and
it's because these people have
essentially just become puppets of the
powerful
yeah i was looking at the snl lineup did
you guys catch that the last snl no i
think it was like ukraine i got to find
out exactly what they're talking about
it's all the stuff you think covet
ukraine what else is on there and it's
not it's not humor anymore it's not it's
like it's reinforcing hey everybody
russia invaded ukraine
and then everyone's like
they're clapping and it's like that's
bad
this strikes me it's just another way to
inject the idea that this is russia's
fault but somebody was saying earlier
today i forget who i was listening to
something like msnbc they're like no gas
prices have been rising since the start
of the year and i was gonna say too that
if you can't afford to pay for four
dollar gallon gas like most of us can't
odds are pretty freaking good that you
also can't afford an electric vehicle
and this is not the time to shame people
for not being able to drive itself
but what's sad about that is that is
what members of the biden administration
are saying between biden and pete bootaj
they're telling people that if you're
worried about the price of gas to buy an
electric car the average electric car
costs like 55 000
and the median household income in
america is like only 10 000 more and
that's what these people are telling us
to do that if you can't afford gas you
should buy a car that you can't afford
if you're homeless just buy a home
how hard could it be why don't wait what
are you doing aren't you buying houses
homeless people yeah
it's so simple it was simple the whole
time i mean
it's a gallon of gas is going to cost 65
000. this is what the left does with the
homelessness problem they're like did
you know there are more empty houses
that homeless people let's just put the
homeless people in the houses and it's
like oh and then when the house burns
down who's gonna be there to help them
because houses need to be maintained
because i'll tell you this we had the
smoke alarms went off here one day and
we have no idea where and then we're
smelling smoke so what do you do call
the fire department get everybody at the
house they gotta go through they gotta
inspect everything and it could be it
could be an electrical fire somewhere in
the walls we don't even know so imagine
you've got a homeless guy clearly
doesn't know how to maintain house
certainly some homeless people are but a
lot of homeless people are mentally
unwell yeah you put them in a house
you're basically shoving the problem
under the rug i'm not surprised that the
the democrat establishment elites people
like booty judge are saying if you have
an electric car you don't have to worry
about high gas prices yeah well if i was
a millionaire i wouldn't have to worry
about it either so case in point if i
was rich i wouldn't be complaining but
for poor people they're like
how is this solving my problems well
here's the thing rich people complain
they just complain about you instead of
their problems as is the case with cold
bear here i think it's uh it's an i i
mean i agree with you homelessness is
mostly an issue of mental illness or
addiction
very often and self-harmed yeah and so
that their whole point about well there
are homes for every homeless person
that's not exactly uh demonstrating that
they understand the issue here and
similarly
inflation and high gas prices are caused
by the fact that we have printed
trillions of dollars
and
that results in prices going up because
you flood the market with excess
currency it's very straightforward stuff
and that they're gonna sit here and
blame russia for it and they're going to
shame you for not uh buying an electric
car you know this morning i bought a
bunch of stuff
yeah so i was like good idea man we
we've been procrastinating on some
things because we're waiting for the new
headquarters to start construction so
i'm like uh look we need cameras we need
the new uh computer and the new you know
live casting equipment stuff
i'll buy it when we when we're ready to
you know like when we're a week out from
the completion of the studio we'll we'll
buy it it'll get here on time and then i
woke up this morning and i saw the news
about shell pulling out of russia and i
was like
i'm gonna buy it all now all of it we're
gonna put in boxes and we're gonna keep
it because it's gonna we're like two or
three months away from from needing it
but if i wait it's gonna go up 30 or
more we should start buying spare parts
for like everything we got
so refrigerator someone was telling us
to buy like 10 cheap honda civics or
something
because then you like they all have the
same parts
you can strip one and then fix all the
other ones so yeah like if you ever
played fallout 3 and you'll have like
two you know repeaters and then when one
breaks you can combine them to repair
the one yeah you know i learned that
from video games so so it's a good idea
yeah yeah it's a good electric though
great so maybe we should do like ethanol
conversions because i can tell you this
i certainly will will will not be able
to create uh gasoline but uh making
ethanol actually ain't that difficult so
you know you wanna you wanna do like
what um
the doc did and back to the future and
just throw garbage in your tank to make
it run right that's flash graphing man
that's what they do they throw carbon
trash into a little vessel and then hit
it with bombarded lasers and turn it
into graphene to quote i think it was
dan aykroyd was it dan aykroyd who did
that snl skit in the 70s where he was
like
don't don't you want to own a five
thousand dollar suit oh yeah smoke a two
hundred dollar cigar drive a fifty
thousand dollar car inflation's not bad
he's pretending to be jimmy carter i
love it well here we go
so if you go by the inflation metrics
um the calculation of the 80s it's
actually the worst inflation since world
war ii oh yeah we're also seeing a
ground war in europe which we haven't
seen since world war ii
so you know i you know what kind of
worries me is if these world economic
forum people really do want a great
reset why wouldn't they advocate for a
full-scale world war iii no-fly zones it
is absolutely infuriating to me to watch
our elites talk about how unworried they
are about this because this is their
fault this is all their fault the fact
that we have massive inflation which is
not affecting them entirely their fault
their sons will not be sent overseas but
yours might because you're a pleb you
don't have an electric vehicle because
you can't afford it too bad should have
thought about that before you were poor
it's like unbelievable the level of
arrogance and disconnection that's what
makes me really mad remember when paris
hilton wore that shirt stopped being fun
i've seen that me a lot lately that's a
funny shirt i like it that meme applies
to a lot of people lately yeah and also
and also what is this where we have
inflation economic downturn and
potentially world war three we skipped
right over the roaring twenties right
supposed to be the we
yeah what are we i was i was expecting
the roaring twenties and they skipped
right right right to world war three we
got that in 2019 kind of what makes me
nervous when we talk about how trump had
the best economy of all time was under
trump and that kind of sentiment it
reminds me of not maybe not of all time
but it reminds me of the roaring 20s
because it's like just pumping inflation
everything looks great but on not really
it's because we're blowing the balloon
up until it explodes you're incorrect uh
unemployment was like at record lows
they don't measure it right they don't
measure people that aren't looking for
work
that's
true but you still had employment going
down among communities like in ways we
haven't seen before i don't think it was
the worst economy when it was going on
but it was inflating and we didn't it
was construed as good because it was you
know a lot more money coming into
people's pockets but it was inflating
that's a function of that's an issue of
inflation if everybody's rich and people
don't want to work you've got to pay
more to incentivize them to work and
that's the problem with ubi so one thing
that happens under a really great
economy is some dude who makes a hundred
grand and it's the most they've made in
a year someone comes home and says you
know i want you to do this job for me
the market rate is two grand he goes i
don't need to do it i've already made a
bunch of money this year and i'm good
and they say okay how about three grand
okay now the demand like you know it
costs more to get that job because
somebody already made too much money and
that can also be a factor in driving up
inflation as well so it's like they want
to keep people poor so that they can
keep prices down it's an interesting
control they have to they this game they
play with the fed and so there's
interesting questions you know we had
will chamberlain on i think i think it
was will talking about the gold standard
yes and he was saying like there are
some interesting problems that happen
when you have no control over the market
because wild things can occur in the
market
bringing some stability isn't
necessarily a bad thing the problem in
my opinion is that the whole thing is
exploitative the whole thing is
exploited the elites take advantage of
it they use it to manipulate and control
they do punitive taxing they say we
don't want people to smoke so we're
intact cigarettes we don't people
driving cars we're gonna tax gasoline
make it expensive they do things like
that they shouldn't do that that's
that's manipulating society for
political agendas but that's how they
use the monetary system to their
advantage
or they tac they tax people without ever
officially saying that they're taxing
them by printing a bunch of money
and the value of everybody's savings and
their current salary decreases so that
we can fund other programs elsewhere but
it was never conceived of by the public
as a tax it kind of feels like hostile
takeover of the crypto market over and
over again when they drive the prices
down and then buy it back up it's
they're hostile takeovers are illegal
now because they used to do it with
companies and it was just so blatant but
now it's with crypto it's not a company
it's just an it looks like an asset or a
so it doesn't it doesn't i don't think
people have realized that it's kind of
the same thing is going on silver and
gold are up
um i think gold
someone want to check the gold price i
think it broke 2k let me see but
you know i think about that i'm like i
do like gold and silver you know
personally to a certain degree but it's
certainly not tracking alongside
inflation
57 20 57 so it's over 2 000. so it
should probably like uh uh in what 2010
i think silver hit like 40 bucks yeah
yeah that was crazy
but if silver has been 20 bucks for 10
years it should be way higher right so
that's why i'm kind of like i don't know
if silver is the best bet in the world
it's better than just sitting on us
dollars that are inflating that are
becoming worthless
so i'll certainly pick some of that up
but i'm not super confident i'm
wondering
this is a question that we've asked
quite a bit
what is a household item
that is used frequently but extremely
hard to make
and so one of the things i hope for wire
like you you you don't go honey can you
pick up copper wire from the hardware
store for us sometimes even if it's used
every day by people yeah so i was
thinking antiseptics because um while
it's probably not that hard to ferment
like certain alcohols to use antiseptics
we we use them frequently you use them i
mean you use mouthwash almost every
single day you're not supposed to do it
every day but for a lot of people use it
a lot you can use you know alcohol and
other alcohols or hydrogen peroxide for
cleaning wounds and stuff like that so
i'm thinking like what's something
that's really hard for an individual
themselves to make that but we use a lot
that will be extremely valuable medicine
yeah medicine for sure yeah we were
talking on i think i think it was the
member's only thing about how horse
epinephrine yeah was like that's right
one 500th of the cost of human
epinephrine even though it's identical
same thing but please don't go buy horse
medicine yeah we talked about that with
thomas massey they they love accusing
conservatives of promoting horse
medicine i've been looking at how
joe rogan took horse stormer yeah um
that you can make out uh fuel from wood
it's very dirty and you can also make
rubbing alcohol from wood yeah
distilling it was it was it methanol so
maybe maybe rubbing alcohol is not
antiseptic is not so hard you can't use
it as mouse mouthwash though that grain
alcohol i think is just for topical
stuff
yeah that's why i was thinking you know
so i was like buy some mouthwash vitamin
c
huge i think vitamin c might be like
there there might come a point where
you're buying stuff in with vitamin c or
you know look
if you live in certain areas where do
you get your vitamin c from serious
question for a lot of people they take
supplements or they're getting it from
oranges from meat actually how much how
much vitamin c is citrus citrus fruits
too but those don't grow in west
virginia
i suppose you can eat some berries and
like pawpaw in august in september and
october very seasonal
but for a lot of people they're going to
be lacking a lot of very important
vitamins so you could walk up and
someone's going to be all scurvy like
and they're going to be like i have this
bottle of water and you'll be like i got
vitamin c and they're going to be like
please strawberries i'm not sure that
there's much vitamin c in meat i've
heard that spinach i think is that when
you're talking about vegetables that's
when you start to get it yeah yeah i
wonder if it's in grass i'm trying to
find out parsley oil grass drink like a
grass tea and get enough vitamin c where
are you going to get your fats from
in like a true apocalypse that's a fish
i mean that's a tough one where are you
going to get you're going to go fishing
yeah not everybody
are you capable of hunting are you
capable of fishing that's a good
question
fish would be good
but a lot of people don't understand so
i think it was like in venezuela they
were telling people to eat rabbits yeah
that's rabbit starvation because rabbits
don't have a lot of fat so you're just
getting
lean protein and it's not enough you
need those fatty acids and stuff like
that
so a lot of people don't realize this
americans have what i refer to as the
shotgun diet
where they eat so much random stuff they
get everything they need and then some
right but if you actually start paying
attention to your diet and start you
know tracking how much you're eating and
what you're eating you'll have to
realize like whoa
when you actually control for what you
eat you better pay attention to where
you're getting certain vitamins from
like vegans have this problem with b
vitamins
because they eat a lot of just like
vegetables and sugars
and a lot of people get their b vitamins
my understanding is from meat and dirt
and they're not getting it so you gotta
take supplements
so i think that's one of the issues
where people might
experience look if gas is is at four
bucks a gallon record high already
and russia was just cut off
what's gas gonna hit there's some
there's some people saying over 200 a
barrel russia was saying over 300 a
barrel so that means we could look be
looking at like eight to ten dollars a
gallon for gas if that's the case
good luck getting anything agreed
anything because that diesel cost is
gonna go way up and that means the cost
of every every single shipping costs are
gonna double you wanna get something or
double the shipping cost inflation's
going to skyrocket and if we get hit
with hyperinflation
man it really does feel like uh the
1920s right tucker germany at least
tucker carlson had a farmer on this show
last week who said that
because of the price increase of wheat
people could see their grocery bills go
up by a thousand dollars a month
that's what this farmer said remember
remember mayonnaise mayo gate yeah i
sure do
during the during the pandemic this this
is almost like a a year ago now there
was a restaurant that said they were
spending something like 200 bucks more
per week in mayonnaise
and
the left saw the story no i'm sorry
republicans saw the story and then
posted something like bite inflation at
work restaurant spends 200 bucks a week
for more mayonnaise so the left saw and
trying to argue with the republicans
claimed the story was fake because they
were like consumer prices are up five
percent so if they're spending 200 bucks
a week and that's five percent there's
no way they're spending that much money
on mayonnaise and it was amazing because
these news organizations or news i do
air quotes started reporting the story
saying restaurant mocked for lying about
mayonnaise costs so i did the
unthinkable
i called the restaurant and i said hi i
saw a story where it said that one of
your found one of your owners partners
said that you were spending 200 bucks a
week more in mayonnaise and you went oh
yeah yeah we have we do 10 of the tubs
per week and they they you know they've
gone up 20 bucks they've almost doubled
in price so yeah it's like 200 bucks a
week and i went okay i mean that's a lot
of mayonnaise though he goes well we got
a 250 person capacity restaurant so you
know we typically we're we're usually
fairly full and the mayonnaise is used
for salad dressings for sandwiches for
dips so you know we go through quite a
bit and i went oh okay thank you do they
know sure it's amazing how for political
reasons they accuse some restaurant who
is just telling the truth of being liars
to suit their political agenda
that's the danger of these people
equally honestly i mean anyone who
points out information that's
inconvenient to them has to be a bad
person they need to assassinate their
character
i found a couple of common ways to get
vitamin c in a pinch dandelion greens
dandelion tea they're a weed so they
grow really fast if you want to grow
those in a farm and pine needle tea
excuse me from pine trees really yeah
chicory also i don't know i do have i
think chicory around here yeah pine
needles aren't that hard to come by we
need more pine trees yeah
we've got the environment for dandelion
tea you say dandelion is incredible it's
so powerful can you eat dandelions you
can't you can really they're really
really good for you yeah do they taste
good i've never eaten one but when do
you eat them do you eat them when
they're like all poofy or to eat them
when they're yellow
um you eat the greens so you don't eat
the flour i don't think you eat the
flour i don't know what if you like pull
a rice into a flour and bake like
cookies with it that could work oh we
actually had watermelon seed flour the
other day and that was really really wow
that was interesting we made like a
carrot cake with it it was a lot of fun
remember we made that cricket bread yeah
yeah yeah it was not good it wasn't i
would eat it with a pinch yeah yeah yeah
yeah i would give it a cricket bread
yeah yeah it was like flour made from
pulverized crickets
interesting because it didn't rise
properly it was back when they were
talking about everyone's gonna eat bugs
and then i was like look i gotta be
honest i have no problem eating bugs if
i have to because like i think people
need to recognize the life is not that
life is not candy canes and rainbows
like sometimes you gotta eat bugs and
and honestly when they're like you will
live in the pod i'm like depending on
where the pot is i would not mind like a
treehouse small little living situation
and you know being responsible yeah you
can actually zipline you can actually
buy crickets as a snack too yeah i
remember i remember tastes good well so
i remember one time so when i was at the
caller we we did this video for our
subscribers
where we had a because it was like when
you know it was like going off of the
you will not eat i will not eat bugs i
will not live in a pod thing we actually
ate some crickets and we bought them
they flavor them you can buy them in
like the same types of flavors that you
do like potato chips
and i had some and
they they didn't taste bad they just
when you eat it you feel like
it all on your tongue and that's like
what was it it's really i don't yeah and
that was like the worst part about it
at least we so i purposefully then
ordered a bag of cricket flour and ian
made a cricket bread
it was kind of nutty but too bitter and
so ian actually mixed flour in with it
because the cricket won't rise one of
the things we could do though and i
think we tried yeah no no no
needs more egg
to get so because because the egg can
help the rice and some rising agent uh
so i would give the cricket bread like a
d-plus
meaning like
you could eat it and probably just you'd
be like
you could probably mix it in with like a
flower bread and then get a lot of
protein out of that that way
yeah we got uh you can get cricket
cookies that i hear actually pretty good
the thing about the bread is that
there's not a lot of flavor or sugar in
it so you're just getting the the
astringent cricketness of it but uh i
gotta i gotta be honest like
i tell you this and this is true of
everybody listening as well if push came
to shove and you were starving and
someone walked over to you with a bunch
of roaches you'd be like oh thank you so
much and you would chow down and you'd
probably it would be the most delicious
thing you've ever tasted no if you're
like you know food tastes better when
you're hungry yep and then
my my thing is you ever have corned beef
hash for breakfast yes for me like the
first bite is amazing the second bite is
pretty good the third bite is okay in
the fourth bite i'm like okay i'm done
like it's just very salty and strong and
like the first bite is like oh so good
when you're hungry food tastes good
and so give it a couple days don't eat
for one day have no access to food and i
will walk up to it with a bag of grubs
and you'll be like
they will taste delicious you'll love it
yummy park
she escaped north korea and man when she
was talking about the starvation that
people are experiencing in north korea
they can't even they can't think
straight they can't even question the
government because all they do is search
for food like there's people on the side
of the road looking for food there's
people dying on the side of the road
from starvation
but all you gotta do is horrifying the
thing you take planks of wood and you
press them into the ground and then the
next day you come out oh yeah flip it
over you lift it up take the bugs eat
them and then move the plank to a new
spot
that's a really good idea yeah and so
that's what uh steve renee was telling
us about chickens that if you want to
feed your chickens and make it cheap you
just put different planks of wood you
know out that's cool and then you come
out and when the chickens are out you
lift up the wood and they all run and
eat the bugs then you move the plank to
another spot you move them all and the
next day you do the same thing because
the bugs keep going underneath them um
there you go
this is our feet this is our future and
yeah post a lot apocalyptic world it's
also our past yeah no i got to be honest
no i got no problem with with being
responsible look i'm not saying
everybody should be eating bugs and
stuff like that but my view is kind of
like
if we all had to be a little bit more
responsible for ourselves the food we
eat i think it's a good thing yes so
we've got chickens we have too many eggs
we gotta start giving them away we're
incubating 56 eggs right now because we
have too many can they be stored frozen
and stored you can store them it's
called glassing i think it's called and
they can be stored for a couple years oh
yeah yeah i was just watching grizzly
man last night you guys ever see that
grizzly man movie that guy that went to
the after oh maybe uh he went up north
somewhere and lived with the grizzlies
and then one of the grizzlies hate them
and it's on video like oh my god verner
herzog did a documentary about it and
the guy's like screaming for his life um
yeah nature's no joke why did the
grizzly eat him uh he was hungry he went
up there during the feeding times before
hibernation he defied all the logic and
was like they're my friends you guys
gotta watch grizzlies
did he have a relationship with the
grizzlies he thought he did he was like
they're my friends except for that with
the machine who i don't trust and it was
the machine that ate him and his
girlfriend it's really a horrific his
girlfriend yeah it's on on video they
didn't take the lens cap off it was just
recording the audio it's freaking
terrifying and you can hear him
screaming and everything for like
minutes and it's just like that bear has
taken its time like nature is not a joke
you do not want to be you versus the
elements we're lucky and when the ammo
runs out they didn't take any defensive
weapons they were like no we're not
going to even have bear spray
he truly believed that they were his
friends i'm trying to figure out you
know things to buy that we'll need
i bought a katana
is that something we'll need like in the
apocalypse
train in the ways of the soul maybe like
20 machetes yeah doesn't need uh
ammunition so this katana was like 50
bucks
and it's really sharp cool it's probably
not good no
but it probably works for a little bit
i'd save it for home defense to be
honest against like animals stuff like
crazy like raccoons and probably just
use it for clear and brush and going
bushwacken or something i mean look i'm
no defense expert or
prepper expert but i would definitely
recommend that people try to get
non-perishables that could last them for
quite a while even if you don't have the
money to buy large bulks of it right now
we're getting to the point where it
could be too late soon so at least every
time you go to the grocery store maybe
buy some extra cans if that's all you
can afford and i'll add this as well
people are really black-pilled about the
economy and the direction it's going to
go in and it very well could get really
really ugly really quickly and that's
not something that i want for this
country but i'll say this
your grandparents and great-grandparents
who lived through the great depression
are probably better people than you and
they're probably more virtuous because
of it so even though we might be facing
really hard times hard times do make
strong men
and
you should hope and pray that you're
able to make it through whatever is to
come with strength and dignity all right
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
the channel share the show with your
friends head over to timcast.com we have
a member segment coming up for you
around 11 or so p.m but let's read what
you guys got going on
all right let's see
not my regret says it's terrible in
michigan too saw 4.55 cents unleaded and
6.22 diesel
it's close to over a dollar in the span
of two days i remember when i was a kid
premium it was like a nickel difference
it was like five cents a gallon
difference for premium mid mid-range and
then the or for like regular middle and
then premium and then after the price
spike it went to like a ten cent
difference now i'm seeing a 50 cent
difference i saw like look at the
pictures like six dollars then like 630
then seven or whatever so it's like the
gap between the the grades is getting
crazy i wonder if sometimes how much the
price is going up is purely because of
inflation and how much if it's
opportunistic by the companies masking
it with inflation and just trying to
make more profit talking gas prices just
prices in general i think i think in
this time of inflation it would be very
beneficial for them to keep their prices
as low as possible i know that there's
been arguments from the bidet
administration for example that they're
doing this because of greed but then the
question is did they just start getting
greedy after you guys printed trillions
of dollars
all right let's see someone chatted and
this isn't a super chat but it's a good
chat with with alerts and it says tim
you're wrong on bugs
a journalist tried to do 30 days of
eating bugs even when starving she
couldn't do it and wanted to die instead
yikes
well all right then yeah you need fish
omg puppy says victoria nuland is deeply
to blame for the conflict in ukraine
today look at oliver stone's documentary
ukraine on fire it's on youtube rumble
and vimeo
interesting
brian bova says nostradamus was right to
the zombie apocalypse starts in russia
what if it is a zombie apocalypse if
you're in a zombie apocalypse and you
find a dead body on the ground if you
didn't put an arrow in its head it's
probably still alive this is what i'm
sorry i just i get so tired of watching
zombie movies or honestly any movie
where it's like they're fighting a bad
guy and they don't finish the bad guy
off beat a zombie or otherwise it's like
dude this this this creature this undead
thing is attacking you and they'll like
hit it and it falls down and then
they'll be like all right everybody
let's start oh no it's biting me now and
it's like well yeah like what do you
think was gonna happen and then they
never ever call them zombies in zombie
movies
yeah well and some they do and they're
and then they're very rare but what
movie was it where they they duct tape
magazines to their arms
oh for armor
that's good scratch armor yeah slashing
well you can't bite through it but the
funny thing is like biting is actually a
really awful way to transmit diseases
so it's just like a bad
theme anyway will there be fair the
human mouth is disgusting there was also
rabies yeah in the movie zombieland with
jesse eisenberg he always had the rule
where he always had to double tap every
zombie that he killed that's right
interesting great rule yeah all right
let's grab super chat easy uh ease zq
says we got 1.5 trillion omnibus bill
consisting of several thousand pages
whose text has yet to be released
congress to vote on it by tomorrow night
at least
all right look i don't know how this
stuff works but marjorie can you just
like slide in a ban repeal the like
abolish the atf just right in the middle
they'll sign it they're not going to
read it they will there you go atf gone
well this is the nfa gone yeah well this
is how dc works they pass these bills
that are like
gajillion pages long that nobody's read
that's written in the dead of night by
lobbyists and special interests that's
how our government works we're not
governed by congress we're governed by
special interests in washington dc yep
all right
and also like this was a you know this
was a thing that uh my friends at
american principles project were
highlighting today which is that the
democrats are trying to put their new
version of the violence against women's
act into this omnibus bill
now that's a misnomer for the title
because part of the bill is any women's
shelter that doesn't allow biological
men has their fun has their funding
taken away does that sound like
preventing violence against women
that's crazy
let's read some more we got janish
partridge who says it is already the 9th
of march in new zealand so happy
birthday new zealand time tim thank you
very much tomorrow is my birthday happy
birthday happy birthday tim happy
birthday jerry wells says almost every
country has bio labs just depends on the
research being conducted in them i
completely agree that is a true
statement and that's why
the problem is
these fact checks need to be thorough
and break down the issues like yes there
are bio labs here
russia has issued statements of concern
we we don't believe they're genuine
these are not included in putin's
demands
these don't appear to be funded by the
u.s i think that's all for are they
weapon labs unconfirmed right what are
they well they did say that it was like
food and drug stuff you know so
all right let's grab some super chats
dark soul poetry says
f ukraine f nato f the old imperialist
club from the eu well there you go
that's one way to put it based
tell us how you really feel
jack sparrow says occam's razor if you
think ukraine the only country to get
poorer after leaving the soviet union
has their own bio labs support their
robust medical program you're a fool yes
we funded it but but it's it's you know
perhaps let's get to the point of that
story we can certainly have our opinions
on it i agree i want to be precise
because i want to have the discussion
around the bio labs i want to have a
discussion around what russia's
motivations are and then we can
investigate them and figure out what
exactly was going on right i do also
want to say
i'll add to your point if you think
ukraine the only country to get poor
after leaving the soviet union is
actually beating russia in a ground war
then um
you are a fool huh nah i i maybe it's a
little bit harsh but they keep saying
like oh ukraine's winning and they're
doing this then yeah it's because nato
is supporting them
they call it the borderland the ukraine
ukraine borderland because i believe in
the past the empires of the west the
french and the english and the empires
of the east the russians the ottomans
would fight in the border land they all
agreed we're going to fight here because
it's flat and then if we level the
universe if we level up to the ground
we're going to level ukraine the
borderlands and not our home territory
so it's just like a torn war zone man
and for that for them to actually be
defending that flat land they're gonna
need massive amount of help all right
beef nasty says just make a zeppelin tim
i did
we we created the let's go brandon blint
we flew it already had live cameras on
and everything
where's the update wikipedia how come
people haven't gone to wikipedia and put
back in that i invented a zeppelin you
see how it works when i don't invent the
zeppelin they claim i do and then when i
do they won't put it back in
it's messed up oh you guys have heard it
i did it's on cast castle vlog you can
take the video and you can put on
wikipedia tim poole did invent a
zeppelin and put a flag on it actually
it was luke's idea let's go brandon
there you go
the kt uh the kl tanker says did you
know on your spotify podcast are ads for
cnn and yourturn.gov vaccines
that's absolutely fine i'm glad that cnn
is buying ads on my show and then i can
take that money to fund a show where i
say that cnn is trash and complete
garbage and you shouldn't watch it
thanks for the money cnn
i also think it's funny the activists
who are like no that's people who are
advertising on their house yeah cnn
congratulations go complain to them
i'm pretty sure like if you want to cnn
and said you know you're advertising on
tim pool's show they'd be like maybe we
don't want to do that
like or maybe they do actually like i
was like when bloomberg was advertising
on my youtube channels
it's kind of the channel he wants to
advertise on because i'm ragging on him
all the time and so he needs to be able
to say his his piece sure you know
sure i guess
that's an interesting thing about um
these the way ads are run today
if we're doing direct sales because this
happens all the time i get an email from
like our sales rep and they'll be like
would you want to sponsor from this this
is the reason we have very few sponsors
why it's mostly like biotrust virtual
shield and maybe a couple couple other
companies here and there because they'll
reach out and be like do you want to
read this and i'll say no
but with youtube and with podcast
automated ads i don't control it
it's totally third party that that you
know makes the ad buys and does the
positioning so i'm just like
i guess it was cnn this time whatever
group b says tim remember when trump
gave a speech at the u.n general
assembly about how the germans were
captive to russia on gas or trump nato
summit about energy deals with russia
both took place in 2018 oh i certainly
remember those that's right that's why
it's always hilarious to me when people
like say that trump weakened our
alliance with nato all he ever wanted
them to do was stop outsourcing their
energy production to russia and actually
pay the two percent of their gdp to
defense that they're supposed to and
that's been interpreted as weakening
nato
i'm cia says you owe a retraction on
coney 2012. last night's show you
claimed jason russell gripped himself in
public this was an exaggeration by the
press see internet historians story of
coney 2012 video he didn't grab himself
in any way i don't know anything about
it i didn't say he was tubing it
[Laughter]
no i like i i i could have sworn as a
video of him like holding himself you
know what i mean like yeah invisible
children boss jason russell arrested for
doing it to himself in public
but national
was he just holding his you know who he
was probably tripping and took all his
clothes off and ran outside was running
around like a monkey i don't know
there's video of him yeah i know that's
why i'm like yeah he was you know he's
holding him still inappropriate right so
i said gripping yeah like i don't know
what else to say you know
gripping
all right bill billy warren says tim ian
and james are correct take a look at
oliver stone's documentary ukraine on
fire it will explain exactly what the
u.s gloria newland and the state
department did there you mean victor oh
it's probably voice tax victoria newland
oh yeah
mr mystery says tim's biden is way more
accurate than sheamuses come on man
you know part two
well anyway
yeah all right tim now do yours i've
never heard it before i can't i can't i
can't i can only i can only
spontaneously do it part of why i love
oliver stone and this ukraine on fire
why i'm excited about ukraine on fire is
because he was in vietnam he got i think
he got drafted he might have he might
have joined and listed but he was over
there and he truly believed in the
mission and the government and
everything and realized why he was there
how messed up it is in operation
northwoods came out and he was like a
vocal proponent of false flags and
you know the the effery that goes on
politically with war
here we go agreeing clover says civilian
contractor here i've been to qatar and
saw someone fall during construction and
no one bedded an eye wild west out there
yikes
shout out to fifa man you're doing a
great the world of great service yeah so
much work and victor rodriguez former
apple employee hated them max absolutely
can get viruses mac os is
compartmentalized so viruses are usually
contained to the downloaded download
folder and end up being force pop-ups
and redirects
interesting it was based on unix by the
way yeah yeah it's just they just it's
it's like obvious you know
which i've never i've never liked apple
and i'm just either
my friends are like i'm gonna spend a
thousand dollars on a computer with the
processing power of another computer
that costs 300 and i'm like why are you
doing that like i have student loans i
don't care now they're like pay off my
student loans and i'm like no they were
vastly incompatible with gaming in the
90s when i was getting into pc gaming
and it was just such a turn off and a
bad taste i got the iphone because it
was the first smartphone but then i
immediately switched to android when
they started doing it apple was like you
can't take the battery out of the phone
it was freakish no i noticed that the
power pc processor instead of intel
right and so they couldn't run anything
cool talking about windows yeah no i'm
talking about yeah apple did not have
intel processors until the macbook
and now they're not an intel anymore
yeah so there's i remember when pentium
2 came out that was crazy
wait a turbo button on a computer yeah
yeah turbo button i don't know was that
what did it do overclock or something
like why not use it then i don't
understand yeah like why have it off
yeah uh probably because your computer
overheats
did it just make games play super fast
or something i remember we went to uh
best buy and we got a computer that was
like 13 gig hard drive oh i got it we
were like dude that's crazy i so i
remember this this was 2005 i was a
little 10 year old boy fry's electronics
with my dad and he handed me a little
usb flash drive
off the shelf and he said sheamus
this can store as much as 82 floppy
disks and i was like what
i was like can we have it he's like yeah
just put your school assignments and
stuff on it like my goodness there's a
little 82 megabyte
a flash drive not like an 82 megabyte
flash drive what would you even do with
that remember
didn't they make floppies like floppy's
they had like 200 megabytes on them or
something
it was like towards the end yeah no one
was using them but it was just like they
had these super high capacity floppy
floppy disks oh yeah i think tape tape
drivers tape discs are still very useful
for backing stuff because they don't
degrade
the first computer i ever put together i
got parts from a thrift store and it was
a windows 3.1 with a tape drive i'm
looking up the turbo button a little it
says here uh the turbo button selects
one of two run states default normal
speed or reduced turbo speed
uh from the mid 90s well yeah they
didn't they have there was like um there
was this new format they looked like
floppies i don't think they would
function in a regular floppy disk drive
but they could store up to 200 megabytes
you need like a separate attachment this
is the concentrator what it suggests the
turbo button uh lets the computer run
slower than the speed for which it had
been designed that's interesting let's
read some more of the engine's power and
efficiency
pyrotech nick says any form of
progressive tax is corrupt a non-corrupt
tax would be flat i do not agree
um i think the issue with a flat tax is
that the richer you are the less
the less you need to survive so the
issue is
for every dollar you earn over well at
this point with inflation i mean yeah i
don't know what the median number is
going to be
but let's say let's say you need a
hundred thousand dollars to have all
your basic needs met that means someone
who makes less than that isn't having
their basic needs met but they're still
being taxed let's then let's say you
make a hundred thousand that means
you're having your basic needs met and
you're paying taxes
for a rich person who's making two
hundred thousand you now have to a
hundred thousand dollars on top of your
salary after taxes however much 60 or 70
to
do with whatever you want like buy extra
hard assets very easily hedge your bets
and start generating wealth very very
easily this makes it extremely easy for
people who exponentially increase their
wealth to increase their wealth further
and gain more and more power in the
system the arguments i've heard from the
libertarian right is that it's a good
thing if people learn how to use the
system to gain power because they have
the merit to learn how to control the
system my argument is i don't like
individuals having disproportionate
amounts of power just based on the fact
they have money in the first place
because some of these people didn't earn
the money they inherited it and then
they never have to worry about earning
anything and you end up with legacies
running governments or running
corporations that's not a good thing how
you solve for it i don't exactly know
but i think that at the very least
progressive taxes look i'll put it this
way i have money and i pay a i pay an
insane amount of taxes and it's
like people only knew like how crazy
taxes get at the highest brackets it is
insane well over 50 percent they want to
talk about american turks ruling 35 now
they have no idea what they're talking
about because when you're running a
company you're doing these things you
get taxed every step of the way when
you're buying the equipment you need
when you're when you're when you're
paying employee salaries when you're
paying yourself the taxes are massive
someone will buy an ad for this for this
company for a sponsor spot we'll read it
and of the money we get more than half
goes to taxes in some ways
it's insane but but
we're yeah we live in the best country
on earth we're making it we're making
awesome stuff all around us
i want to make a point here regardless
of how you feel about having a flat tax
or a progressive tax you mentioned
inflation and income brackets and this
is going to be something that you have
to look out for in the future here back
in the 80s after the inflation of the
70s reagan came along and he adjusted
the tax code because we had a
progressive tax code and so there were
people who prior to the 70s were making
significantly higher amounts of money
than they would need to survive so they
were taxed at a higher rate but after
the 70s because inflation had gotten so
bad people who were in that income
bracket were not necessarily wealthy
anymore so he adjusted those brackets
and he was accused
of slashing taxes for doing that now he
did cut taxes in other ways but it was
argued that that was this horrible
regressive thing to do so i want people
to watch out for this as
inflation gets worse
and as it becomes more expensive to
survive
people are going to be pushed into
higher income brackets that have a
higher taxation level when they're
really just breaking even or making ends
meet so the taxes once a conservative
comes along to try to adjust that
they're going to accuse him of slashing
taxes and they're going to say in this
environment where so many people are
going hungry how could you even think
about cutting taxes on the rich i think
like i think um wealth taxes make no
sense stupidest idea i've ever heard
but i think the higher brackets need a
higher percentage and we have to stretch
and adjust which means like what kind of
what you're saying for a certain income
level maybe around like the 200
thousands we lower the taxes and then
for over half a million to a million you
slightly increase and then for like you
know a million to five million it goes
up and then for like 5 million to 15 it
goes up the issue is that i think the
tax bracket stops at what like 250 250
million no 1000. oh oh yeah
i think it's like no it might be yeah i
think it's like two i think what's the
last bracket like 250
might be it might be like 500. so that
means somebody who's making um
in terms of income like 13 to 14 million
a year these ceos like colbert i think
it's 16. some people are getting 50
depending on the contracts they have
um depending on what industry they work
in they're paying the same percentage as
somebody who's making 200 000. that's
one of the problems i have it's not an
issue of the progressive or flat tax
it's that if you're going to do it you
got to do it right you want to have a
flat tax okay fine man far bait for me
to argue i'll have more money you don't
do a progressive tax well then you need
to keep going with the progressive taxes
so this is interesting i was looking
into what the brackets are and we have
an article on the irs website or a page
saying that they're providing tax
inflation adjustments for 2022 which is
sort of a start but i'm very curious to
see how they're adjusting it considering
based on the way that our government
actually measures inflation they don't
really give you the full picture
what do you guys think about the whole
taxation is theft oh sorry i thought you
were done no no i guess my point is we
are still going to need adjustments to
the tax code
because of inflation my issue is as much
as i can be like i understand the idea
of a progressive tax to kind of curtail
the power of private individuals who
accumulate too much we don't want to
stop them from ever being able to work
but we do want to make sure that you
know we're constraining inequality when
inequality gets one of the precursors to
civil to societal collapse is inequality
i know a lot of people maybe don't like
the idea but but it's true when the well
when the wealthy have too much power
just disproportionate power and are
saying things like just buy an electric
car yo you get people losing their minds
like people right now you're gonna
you're i'm telling you man you got
people who are like i can't buy guests
and colbert being like i drive a tesla i
don't care
yeah people are gonna be like okay
that's it these powerful elites are
screwing us over biden is halting gas
leases for climate change issues and
then someone's gonna start screaming so
you need to have some way to like
constrain these issues
the problem is giving the money the
government doesn't solve the problem
yeah being like we want to make sure
that ultra rich people aren't saying let
them eat cake the problem is giving
money the government just recycles the
money among the elites because at least
it doesn't matter if you're in
corporation or government they're all
big they're all they're all birds of a
feather flocking together up top yeah
exactly i used to be extremely
libertarian and at this point i don't
necessarily have the same argument from
principle
about certain forms of taxation but
ultimately i still don't trust anyone in
government to spend the money better
than a wealthy person would if you just
left them alone with it how do you
justify owing the federal reserve more
money than we have
that's a good question yeah i'm not sure
like well
yeah let's read some more super chats
here
murph says i heard a retiring general
contractor say once don't be surprised
that if one day plumbers and carpenters
start making more than heart surgeons
skilled master laborers will be in high
demand absolutely cheese heart surgery
is pretty skilled labor
but i see where your point jeremy wien
says spruce has vitamin c oh good to
know all right we have we have a bunch
of crazy berries out here we have winter
berries there's a tree that's in the
winter drops berries all winter
i don't know that was a thing the
chickens go nuts for it though you know
whatever we also in the summer we have
wine berries everywhere yeah those are
good everywhere it's crazy you walk
outside it's like a red like just red
everywhere and you can walk them and you
take them and eat them i saw a guy pull
over on the side of the highway get out
of his car hop over and just grab a
bunch and get back in his car and start
eating him it's crazy
all right pardaxalis says good reporting
from elod on the people's convoy was
only able to find his videos on tim
cast's website is this on purpose seems
like a failure to promote them maybe a
tim cast reports youtube channel is in
order i think we put them on rumble
cause we
don't want them on i don't know
maybe we shouldn't think about it we put
them on the website um and honestly
we're trying to
produce more content for the website
that is substantive and valuable for
people so
uh as a member at timcast.com you are
funding this kind of reporting from our
reporters on the ground and it was
expensive
absolutely expensive as we as we
expected it would be but uh it's okay
let me let me just let everybody in on a
an industry secret
the coverage that we did of the people's
convoy from when we started to when it
finished i think it's still technically
ongoing um
cost us
a lot
thousands
and has made us
nothing
we don't we don't we don't generate
money off of like ad revenue from it and
technically we could argue
because we're mostly a membership
website it's just a component of what
makes the site valuable for you as a
member but it's free content so that's
why i just say look we take money and we
spend it on doing good reporting and
getting the reporters out there to talk
to people and be honest about what's
happening and that's expensive i don't
expect to make a lot of money i expect
to make a great website where people
want to support us
and they become members because because
we do good work there you go
all right let's grab a few more of these
the spen spence fencer hey ian put wood
in an airtight box then burn the box
distill vapors from the boxes cooled
condense a fire you have wood alcohol
now wow get gooder man really wait is
that it
distilled vapors from the box
i didn't know that that's really
interesting
dilly dally says spruce needles are very
high in vitamin c wow i didn't know that
i don't know if we have ian for some
reason bought like 50 gallons of vinegar
only 0.2 percent of your daily vinegar
or vitamin c in red wine vinegar now the
other ones seem to have vitamin c in
them but yes we have vinegar like people
are always like hey tim why is there so
much vinegar in your storeroom and i'm
like i don't know ian bought it
it never goes bad but it's a great
seasoning agent uh if i was gonna make
like a tea desperate situation i get
some tree bark some grass vinegar and
salt and it would be like a broth
i guess you can take like malt vinegar
and put it on your potatoes oh for sure
you can rub it on wounds i mean
especially the white vinegar
can't you use it for some kind of like
chemical processes to strip out baser
elements from other
compounds i don't know deeply on the
chemistry i'm not sure i've heard i
think so but i'm a chemist
yeah
definitely learning chemistry is
important
the spence spencer says copper destroys
vitamin c no copper cookware for vitamin
c interesting very interesting
all right let's grab just a couple more
here
true hello says part korean podcaster
tim poole does not know dandelions can
be eaten in fact he does not i knew you
could make tea because ian talks about
it so much
dandelions
i used to be allergic to them because i
ate so much sugar it turns out years
later no i don't sneeze around them
anymore all right let's grab this one
cornbread says tim if a progressive tax
is the answer what are your thoughts of
a progressive sales tax base on the
price of goods higher the price the more
the tax income tax in my opinion is
theft i honestly don't know because as
much as my issue here is curtailing
equal
income inequality so that you don't have
oligarchs
uh now let me explain when you have
oligarchs when you have a very few
handful of elites they buy up all the
buildings and property the building will
cost a million dollars to buy but the
rent will be 500 bucks a month and you
think to yourself how is that possible
well it's simple the rich only trade
among themselves and the poor people are
shut out from ownership from the
ownership economy i think that's really
really bad and it results in extreme
tyranny i don't think taxes necessarily
solve the problem because then you're
just giving money to government and
government just screws around and does
stupid things like indoctrinate kids in
schools so i don't have all the answers
my friends it's really really difficult
and that's in blackrock's like doing
exactly blackrock's doing a lot of that
where they're buying up all this you
know
middle-class housing and jacking up the
rents for everybody basically pricing
middle class home buyers out of the
market i say we do this jd says fried
dandelion flours are delicious tastes
like fried mushrooms you do it when
fresh and yellow well all right we're
gonna do it let's look up a fried
dandelion recipe
see if we can we can do you know ian's
survival course on the cast castle vlog
or something beautiful and we'll bread
them
and fry them up that's awesome and then
dip them in some kind of like chipotle
ranch
all right let's see fried zucchini but
with dandelions i love it i mean i don't
know bees apparently love chilling out
on the dollar salt pepper this is basic
i bet it's so good for you let's try it
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel tell your friends about
the show if you really do like it and
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our journalists and to see
our members only segment which is coming
up just around 11 p.m we'll publish it
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me at tim cast greg do
you want to shout anything out yeah you
can follow me on twitter at greg
underscore price 11 and on instagram at
greg.price11 um 2022 coming up and my
company's working with a lot of great
american first candidates to get them
elected and get republicans in who will
actually keep their promises and we're
working really hard to do it right
wonderful uh my name is sheamus coughlin
i have a youtube channel called freedom
tunes we make educational cartoons and
political satire we just released a
video today on our military's diversity
requirements and how that might affect
us in our preparations for a potential
war with russia or china so please check
that out i think you guys will
enjoy it and thank you so much for
watching i'm ian crossland i just let
you guys know i rolled a hundred earlier
i didn't tell anyone and i just wrote i
rolled a 60. i would never lie
i would never lie follow me at ian
crossland.net
if you'd like to and um find the love
within yourself bro i love you
i was going to say today i i came up
with a new wish the only thing i want in
life is the ability to build a house out
of ammunition out in the country that's
my only dream now i just want to like
escape and make sure that i can defend
myself and i just wanted to say too
before i go these are depressing times
but these are the hard times that will
make ourselves and our children very
strong this is what happened with our
grandparents who surprised great
depression
anyway you guys can follow me on twitter
and mines.com at sarah patch lids we
will see you all at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you